this is jaco podcast number 289
as the seals from zulu platoon inserted
into a rice paddy near where they had
taken fire
nelson's huey a uh-1
bravo gunship commenced a right turn at
80 feet
above the ground to cover them
lieutenant junior grade
carl nelson a fire team leader at
hal three detachment one commanded two
sea wolf gunships during
zulu's last mission he already had flown
more than 600 combat missions
his co-pilot lieutenant junior grade
earl
shout controlled the m134 miniguns
while petty officers michael dobson and
tom
clavon fired the left and right
respectively
m60 machine guns from the doors
lieutenant junior grade
edward dyer would pilot the huey
uh-1 lima sea lord transport
that would insert and later extract zulo
zulu
from a very hot landing zone
shout worked the lz's edge with his mini
guns
while dobson and clive clavon fired
their m60s
the seals patrolled northeast and then
east on a dike separating two rice
paddies
and then moved north to one
perpendicular to the first as they
advanced the enemy began
firing from well-concealed and in
positions on a dike covered with heavy
vegetation
the seals and nelson's gunship
immediately returned fire
as the patrol continued closer toward
the tree line the seals took accurate
withering fire
from both sides of the dike
point man roland fell shot through the
groin
he was hit again as he crawled for cover
seconds later telfer was shot in both
legs
both seals managed to return fire
despite their wounds
but the severity of their injuries and
the immediate necessity to extract them
soon took them out of action
lieutenant jg richards immediately
radioed nelson
for fire support as he and lawrence
advanced under fire to assist
the two seriously wounded seals
christened the hulk by his fellow seals
lieutenant jg tom richards was well
liked and respected
and he enjoyed a reputation as a highly
capable operator
he was a native of bright waters new
york and a graduate of bay shore high
school
where he wrestled and played football
following graduation he attended
villanova university on a
navy rotc scholarship there he lifted
weights and routinely bench press 400
pounds
he was commissioned in ensign in the
naval reserve
in 1969. as lieutenant jg richards
dragged roland to cover one round passed
through richard's right hand
hating the stoner machine guns pistol
grip
[Music]
nevertheless lawrence hedge and futrell
returned fire
richards continued to expose himself to
enemy fire to drag the wounded to cover
when the automatic weapons man futrel
was shot in the chest
he cried out i'm hit i'm hit
lieutenant jg richards sensing the
rising panic in fruttrell's voice
suspected the man was going into shock
to distract him richards ordered futrel
to shut up and return
fire futrel briefly did so with his m-60
and did not go into shock as futrell
became semi-conscious
richards pulled him back as well
when lawrence and hedge ran out of
ammunition minutes later
richards passed them the linked 556 ammo
for his now inoperable stoner machine
gun
the squad regrouped behind a dike and
richards urged the seals to keep pouring
fire into the enemy
as he radioed for emergency extraction
as the battle raged extraction became
imperative
including himself richards had four
wounded men
three of them critical for lieutenant
j.g
nelson and the sea wolves
there was no hesitation he said
quote my crew knew that leaving anyone
behind
was not an option
when nelson saw richards dragging the
wounded seals to cover
he alerted dyer to get ready for
extraction and descended to cover it
from an altitude of about 50 to 70 feet
from the ground lawrence and hedge
provided covering fire with their
stoners
nelson's gunship hit the enemy with
devastating rocket and mini gun fire
while dyer urgently searched for the
seal's exact location
on a second pass dyer spotted them
huddled next to a dyke and came in
hot bleeding off air speed during his
approach as the slick hovered
skids wet in the rice paddy richards
dragged each of the three wounded seals
in turn over the dike then through the
rice paddy to the helicopter
lifting each aboard with his one good
hand
richards later wrote with one hand it
was probably my heaviest lift i ever
made
best one too
enemy fire intensified during the
loading
lawrence still providing covering fire
was about to climb aboard when dyer
began to pull pitch
for liftoff as enemy rounds hit the
fuselage
lawrence grabbed the slick skid and held
on for dear life
until the hulk reached down with his
uninjured hand
and hauled lawrence aboard
having flown more than 600 combat
missions with scores of those flights in
direct support of
two seal teams nelson vividly remembers
the scene
unfolding below his gunship as the
platoon
struggled to survive
nelson recalls quote watching a wounded
tom richards
under intense enemy fire drag each of
his wounded seals to safety
across a series of rice paddy dikes and
load them into the sea lord kilo
it was the most heroic act that i have
ever witnessed
tom richard's heroism rates a navy cross
at a minimum he directly
saved the lives of his platoon
and that's an article from the naval
institute
you can find it online and if you fast
forward from that event
which took place in 1971
fast forward about 20 years to 1991
and i was a new guy at seal team one and
it was a saturday morning and i was in
the gym at seal team one alone
cranking some metallica on the stereo
system
and when i say cranking i mean it was
ear damaging levels
of noise because i was young and stupid
and then the hulk the hulk walked in
and he was wearing his gym clothes and
he was there to get a workout
the same guy this now who was lieutenant
jg this is now captain richards
legendary seal that you just heard about
it's now 20 years later
and of course i knew who he was we all
knew who he was he was the hulk
then he walked into the gym to get his
workout on and so i respectfully walked
over to the stereo
and and turned turned it down turned the
dial about halfway
back to bring it to a normal listening
level
and as i did that the hulk shouted hey
i looked over at him and he said turn
that back up
and i said yes sir and i did
and you fast forward another six or
seven years on top of that and i was
walking in
to the admiral's office
now admiral tom richards the admiral in
charge of all the seals
and i was going to interview you with
him hoping to get a letter of
recommendation for selection
so i could get my commission and become
a seal officer
and he gave me that recommendation and i
did end up getting selected
and i'm certainly thankful to admiral
richards for that but more important i'm
thankful for what
he did for america and for the teams
and for me in the end
and therefore i am also thankful
for those helicopter pilots and crews
for getting him
and his platoon out of there
and these are the same helicopter crews
that risked
their lives time and time again
to get the seals out of the worst
possible
situations these were
the legendary sea wolves the u.s navy
helicopter
attack squadron 3.
and this is a unit
is the most highly decorated naval
aviation unit
collectively awarded in vietnam five
navy crosses 31 silver stars two legions
of merit
219 distinguished flying crosses 156
purple hearts
101 bronze stars 142 gallantry
crosses over 16 000 air medals
439 navy commendation medals
228 navy achievement medals six
presidential
unit citation citations and two
meritorious unit commendations
and we have had the honor of having ac
wolf pilot
on this podcast once before dennis
rowley podcast 153
if you haven't listened to that go and
check it out
but tonight it is an honor to have two
more
sea wolf pilots with us john farr
and carl nelson the same carl nelson you
just heard me read about
who provided cover fire while zulu
platoon
extracted from a serious
gunfight our relationship in the seal
teams
with the sea wolves in vietnam will
never be forgotten
and therefore it is an honor to have you
two gentlemen
with me here tonight thank you thank you
for coming
happy to be here so i know
um well i know i could sit here and just
listen to you guys tell stories about
vietnam for the entire time which is
which we will get to
but to start off a little bit uh let's
start
a little bit about where you guys came
from and and how you grew up just so we
have some background
what do you think john you want to start
and john you're the reason you're
was your son connected us right yes eric
my son he was one that's a marine
and he's big in jiu jitsu so he would
love this place
so he does quite a bit of that but yeah
he's the one that's uh
was in the military well thanks to him
thanks to eric for for linking us up
and and it's outstanding to have you so
where'd you guys grow up
john i grew up in the chicago area north
of chicago
went to high school there and i went to
a small college in
indiana st joseph's college which is in
rensselaer about halfway between notre
dame
and purdue okay and my senior year
there was a navy recruiter came down
looking for uh
recruiting for the navy uh flight
program and i actually so what year is
this
this would have been 1968. okay
so vietnam is full-on yes yes
and uh and that was the year they had
the lottery for the draft okay
and i got the paper i started at 365
looking for my number
and i said geez i missed it so i started
at the top when i went through it again
i said
they don't have my number in here i flip
the paper over the first number picked i
believe was may 8th
the second number picked was april 24th
which was my birthday
so there's no doubt where i was going
and at the same time i was looking for a
job you know graduating from college and
everything
and one of the first questions they ask
is well what's your draft status
i said well let's say one and most
people say well
why don't you come back after your
service and then i interviewed with
burl's corporation
they never asked the question and i
never provide the information and i got
hired
so i got hired by boroughs graduated
started working with them in the
meantime i passed this
flight exam down in college and he said
well now you need to go up to
glenview for an interview and a physical
and i lived probably 20 minutes from
glenview in
northern chicago so i said this is great
so i went up to glenview
my main real reason for going up there
was on saturday
night i'd go down to rush street for the
night and this is back home
so i did that went through the physical
and everything went fine
and i didn't hear anything for a while
because you got to take something go
through the process
and then i started working at burroughs
what kind of company was burroughs
burroughs was a computer company
sold calculators or vending machines at
the time
and uh so i started working i was going
to say a computer company in 1968 it's a
little bit of a stretch right
well well the calculator is at the
machine but they did become one of the
larger computer companies competing
against ibm
in fact later in my career i had sold
the largest
computer that burrows made at the time
to the university of chicago medical
centers
just before they merged with spiri got
it but that's we're off the track
so anyway i uh started working
then i got a notice from the army to
come in for my army induction
physical about a week after that i got a
call
from the navy saying congratulations
you've been selected for the navy's
flight program and i says well i just
started a job i can't do this
and the guy says son you're in the navy
when would you like to report
and i said well what's the latest stage
you could give me and it was october
i think october 18th i said okay i'll
take that
so now i got to go in and tell my boss
i'm going to go in the navy
so i went in early one morning because
he was always in early and
sat down talked to him says joe i went
through this
program and i've been selected for the
navy flight program
as it turned out he was a marine fighter
pilot during world war
ii wow and he says hey this is a once in
a lifetime opportunity
you can't pass that up girls will always
be here
so i worked the summer with them and at
the end they had a little party for me
had this big cake they had a bunch of
little airplanes on and
and gave me a kind of a nail clipper kit
that i have to this day
and uh so that's how i ended up in the
navy
when you were when you were growing up
so you were going to high school
in like the early 1960s yes i graduated
from 63 from high uh
and it sounds like you were pretty uh
you said you had a plan
you know you wanted a job you kind of
had it you you knew what you you knew
that you were going to move forward in a
positive way yes very much so
yes well in my my father was was in a
corporate world
business and as a side story he was
actually eisenhower's personal mess
sergeant all during world war
ii he went over as patton's mess
sergeant
eisenhower found out about him brought
him on his staff
and so he was with him for four years
and i might as well tell the story
yeah finally no no wonder is that cool
there was some conflict between
eisenhower and pat he took his best
freaking cook
and so uh then finally before my dad
passed away we got him to write his
memoirs
just for the family and carl many of our
friends have read it
and in there at one point
he was coming back to the states and so
he asked people on his staff
would you like to come back to the
states and of course all his
so this was eisenhower was coming back
to meet with roosevelt
for just like a week or so of course all
his movements are top secret so he wrote
a letter to my mother
and says meet me at dc at this hotel and
it's all coated so he came back and of
course
nine months later i'm around of course
my mother lived in elmira new york
that's where i was born and of course
nobody knew my dad had been home
and talk in the neighborhood yeah over
the back
so anyway eisenhower bought me a war
bond
and at some point they'd cashed that in
i wish it had kept it been really worth
something today
but i do have the letter signed by
eisenhower authorizing the purchase of
that war bond when i was born
outside but my dad served on the staff
for
about four and a half years i was
probably a year old before i ever saw my
father
but he thinks the world of eisenhower
and says he's never saw
eiser do anything that would challenge
his integrity his honesty or his
reputation it's impressive you don't
hear that very much anymore these days
you know
we could use eisenhower now be nice
all right carl yes where the heck did
you come from
i was born a poor black child i actually
uh believe it or not i was born and
reared in the panhandle of texas between
memphis and turkey texas and hall county
there was a little spot of dirt and
that's where i was born
and maggie and dude's number three child
and
i was the first nelson male to graduate
from high school
so i went to college they thought i was
a flipping genius i mean
that kid must know everything right so
what did your parents do for work
uh they were children of sharecroppers
and sharecroppers themselves we didn't
own anything but
raise cattle and get a cash crop which i
always got a kick of the term cash
because
we never made any money on it and that
was cotton
and uh how many people that you know i'm
sure that
drug a cotton sack at five six seven and
eight nine years old
every fall our school started early like
in august
let out for a month in september october
whenever the cotton
was ready to harvest and of course
we needed all the family to pick the
cotton because there just wasn't enough
labor
and uh so dragging a cotton sack was uh
and of course the rate going wages those
days
was when you paid somebody and that
wasn't often was a
a dollar a hundred penny a pound for
picking cotton
and uh my dad picked a thousand pounds
one day
a long day most i ever got was like 200
but i was a little guy
so that's my roots and we moved to
oregon when i was in grade school and
and it was a great relief getting away
from that damn cotton
but the downside was
i'm chopping and cutting wood you know
the old story goes i was
15 before i knew my name wasn't get wood
i had to get wood all the time
and of course being a very wealthy
family i carried water too we didn't
have a well
we had to get water from a couple miles
away so i'm carrying water
and uh sounds like a lot of racial ultra
stories my kids
yawn and roll their eyes they've heard
them but uh
i'm really proud of my roots and and uh
it's interesting i
my goal was to be a high school football
coach first of all i thought i was going
to be
a professional athlete i was sure i was
going to be an nfl as
a middle linebacker well uh
i did get drafted but the real world was
there was a war going on
um i
i had just gotten married and i thought
you know i had a younger brother in the
army
in vietnam and this is 1966
when i graduated and uh year after john
i'm surprised by the way to hear i was
very surprised to hear that
tom richards finished high school and
and john farr that's
breaking news on the same program you
get it choco
but uh um
i got a dream job i i thought if i don't
if i don't i'll do the tryout
in san diego i would do the try out if
if i don't get a real job that i really
first class job i want i want a first
assistant job in a high school and a
large high school
in in oregon and i got that job so i
i didn't go to camp and uh
but then i had the guilt setting in all
year long
and my brother's still serving he's
going for another tour in vietnam so
i resigned my i was to be the head
football coach
of springfield high school the following
fall and it was like
april may and i just i couldn't do that
i
resigned that job i went uh my
department had dropped boyce pe in
chemistry in high school
my chemistry department head was a guy
named john vogt and john
was a naval aviator he says what are you
going to do and i said i think i'll
probably join the marine corps i don't
know
he said no don't do that go fly
so sandpoint naval air station was open
in those days
up in seattle washington he says come
with me to reserve weekend and
and i went flying with him and then we
hung on the oak club and i was on the
stage dancing with some
polynesian ladies and i thought i could
do this
i could do this job so i
i took the test and did the interview
and
and i i was in class 3268 in the fall of
and pensacola office edited aoc class
and john you were 38 38 60 it was six
weeks later
okay okay so here we go so did you guys
meet each other but after that when you
got into the actual
aviation training program yeah we met in
vietnam
yeah okay yeah we got to be friends
there he was always enough far enough
behind me that i didn't really get to
know him
only three months but you know as you go
through his pretty intensive training
right
and not a big socializer norvis john i
don't think and
we worked pretty hard and so i really
got to know john
in vietnam matter of fact
i think we looked in the logbook today
my logbook's somewhere in the bottom of
storage
in sanger california but i think we flew
together probably a couple dozen times
oh yeah and he was my as we called the
today we called it the clearance pumpkin
got it he was my clarence pumpkin so and
a damn goodman by the way it's uh
i don't want to make him feel too good
about himself today but he
you know it's critical every job in a
cockpit is a critical thing
combat or not but uh
getting where you're going and all
systems being
switches in the right position and when
you roll in and put me hot that means
we know what we're going to do with the
intervalometer whether we're going to
fly a
fire power or two pair and
keeping an eye on things as a co-pilot
besides operating the miniguns or
whatever else he does
so john was excellent and then and
having a co-pilot knows what he's doing
more than once you have to fly with guys
and you probably have too john
you look over and say don't touch i dang
bang
just don't touch anything i'll let you
know when i want you to do something
but john wasn't that kind of guy he was
a he was uh
he was in the mode he was a good guy
so when did you guys figure out or get
assigned
helicopters as opposed to whatever else
the navy has to offer
is that happening at flight school at
the end of flight school yeah well you
go through flight school
and you go through primary training
which is flying to t-34
the advanced training which is flying to
t28
it's after that after you've done your
carrier landings and your
instrument flying your formation flying
and stuff like that either go
multi-engines jets or helos
in my situation my class they were
needing heel pilots for vietnam
so they took my whole class and said you
guys are going helos
and for me it didn't it wasn't a burning
desire for one or the other
there were some people that wanted
multi-engine because they wanted to go
with the airlines or people who wanted
to go jets
because you wanted to go jets and i told
the guy says well i'd like to fly the
big transports and he said well
you should have joined the air force so
so going with heels
was fine with me and got through the
program i'm glad i did
and i think flying in hell-free was
probably the last of the
world war ii type flying as long as you
brought the plane back in one piece
they really didn't care you know what
you did there was a lot of there were
there were rules and flight rules but
you know the job was to get the mission
done
and that was the main thing whatever it
took to get the mission done that's what
you needed to do
i i was in flight school in my i had my
flight and struck my primary flight
instructor
was a guy named i'll say his name johnny
henkel johnny's retired in florida
i just called him another day to thank
him i haven't talked to him since 1969.
and so like on the seawolf mail list
that you get comes in with addresses
numbers i said there's hankel happy gang
that's the same guy
bet i called him up a lady answers the
phone
uh who may have said his calling i said
tell him carl nelson's calling like he
knows
like he remembers 42 years ago
and so more than that 52 years ago i'm
sorry
so he comes on the phone cautiously like
i'm not buying anything tap the voice
hello i said johnny henkel and says
who's calling he didn't admit to
anything
well like i said hey i'm a flight
student yours from february of 1969.
softly field 234 he says jesus christ
really and i said i'm sure you remember
me and he said actually
i don't i said i know you don't but
here's what he did
i i was getting ready to solo and i
thought i was going to fly just because
i
joined i left my teaching and coaching
job i went in the military because i
wanted to serve in vietnam where my
brother was serving
and he was serving actually
back up the clock i when i got into
officer candidate school he was serving
sadly he was killed in action in
november 23rd 1968.
so 22 year old young man second tour
infantry 25th infantry and uh
so anyway i was in a hurry to get there
i wasn't trying to get even that wasn't
my goal i just wanted to serve and
i wanted to get to vietnam and i thought
jess was the only way to get there
i knew i couldn't do it in the transport
i didn't want to fly mail to saigon oh
god bless
the mail guys but and so
i've read about there was a pool in
advanced training in in mississippi
i thought oh my god um and then nixon's
trying to stop the war
good lord that guy's trying to ruin my
plan so i got
i was pretty depressed and what was that
what was the pool what do you mean there
was
well there were in in flight training
they try to keep them moving through
quickly that they're on a schedule to
get students through the syllabus
every flight from primary to advanced
and after advanced i mean after primary
you go to
you go to meridian mississippi to
advanced jet training
or you you go to uh
the ellison yeah the the t28 flying
where they're they're preparing it for
fixed swing or helicopter or for for a
multi-engine or helicopter
and so that's where the decision was
made after you finish primary and
softly field vt-1 they called it the
t-34
mentor so
i was you know i'm getting down to about
three or four more flights to go and i
and and a pool would be where there was
a weather hold up or a maintenance hold
up or whatever
and the students were backed up got it
and so instead of getting through
meridian which was kind of intermediate
training
instead of getting through meridian in
six weeks it might be
three four five months and i thought
good lord i will never get out of here
because after meridian you got to go to
kingsville and beeville and then you get
your wings
and then you go to a rag and it you know
it's a long time
i didn't have much time from the time i
started flight school until i got my
wings
i was 11 months and nine days i was in a
hurry it was an 18-month program
john went through pretty quickly too
i was in a hurry well that day hankel
says
what's what's wrong you seem a little
down i said i'm way down here's the deal
they've got a pool
and meridian i'll never get out of this
damn place and the president's going to
stop the war
what am i going to do this is awful and
i gave up my great coaching job
and he says what are you doing tonight i
said
i'm studying sir i wasn't studying
he says come to my house give me the
address i go to his house
my wife and i and this is you know he's
a jg pretty important guy when you're an
ensign yeah and he's got his wings and
everything and i thought
wow you know i'm going to an officer's
house and he's a senior officer
i got there and we have i don't know
what we had for dinner i didn't
remember i was just nervous you know and
what do i do how do i act
trying to remember all the charm school
stuff they told us well
he brings out eight millimeter movies
hal
three movies and i went oh
my god where what is that
and he told me and i went man i would i
i flew out of his house and i flew all
the way through to get my wings else and
and then i sweated elson because at my
week to get my wings they only have two
slots for hal three
can you believe that two slots buzzy
bazelle and i
buzzy past great guy great friend but
dick buzzle and i got the orders
so is that the first time you heard of
hal three first time i heard of how
three was from henkel
at vt-1 when he showed me the home
movies
and uh and i didn't tell anybody about
it like my secret i wanted
i wanted to make sure i got the job i'm
not giving any leads to anybody
so it was a blessing and i'll tell you
i'm
i'm talking too much and i'm getting
support for john here but
greatest thing that probably not
outside of the birth of my two daughters
the greatest thing that happened to me
because
of the mission was incredible incredible
guys to fly with
and working with seal teams and with the
boats
really i a mission we were needed
and it there's not a better mission on
earth than that
i thought it was when um
when you get assigned to hal three out
of flight school where do you go
well the first thing we had to do is we
had to go to fort rucker for three weeks
for gunnery training
because the navy didn't have any gunnery
training for the helos or anything
the army had that so we spent three
weeks in fort rucker which is
in alabama went through gunnery training
then we had to go through seer school
for escape invasion and
that so we went through that and that
was interesting
and i did mine in little creek and
actually was out in the field
in the coronado and i can remember after
that and you're out there for about
three or four days
and coming back they were on a bus
bringing us back to the base after this
then they stopped at this hamburger
place and i hadn't had anything to eat
you know for three or days so went and
got a
cheeseburger and i can taste that
cheeseburger until today
the best cheeseburger i've ever had
and uh but then we got back and then you
got orders it was actually about six
months from the time we finished flight
school before i got to vietnam which was
the first of august and i got my wings
in february
there's two of us that got our wings the
other was a marine pilot
and uh he was flying cobras and he was
actually killed in vietnam
did hal three have any presence in
america
like was there a headquarters here or
anything so you didn't even
you was that's it you're just kind of on
your own working through the system
actually squadron was commissioned and
decommissioned in vietnam yeah yeah
that's
that's it's like the only one that's
commissioned and recommissioned
in a combat zone right so there's but
there's no press there's no headquarters
back here
nothing no so you don't even meet your
team
until you get to vietnam there you go
right
i just had the pleasure by the way i go
back to louisiana
annually because and i'll say it here
one of my name to be unnamed but
one of my door gunners uh unfortunately
is in prison in angola not a good place
to be
louisiana life and
well on this trip um i got to meet a guy
92 year old robert spencer
retired navy captain the first
commanding officer of hal three
he stood the squadron up yes he did and
he's uh if you saw the scramble the sea
wolves
he's in there and uh quite
a character and he'd go to his house
and he'll smoke 25 30 cigarettes in an
hour and i was there
and drank eight or ten bottles of beer
right there in a little cooler right
next to his chair
talking to his chair great guy great guy
how what's up what's the uh oh go ahead
well i was gonna say he's a 92 he's
probably doing pretty well
but uh so my first when i got to health
free then we got to ben tui
and then he had the first part of you
have these fam flights just to get
familiar with the area
and one of my first flights i was just
telling kyle about this today that
uh one of my first flights was to
hoist a three-holer down to debt six
expand on that so so then carl says well
we built our three hole here
so the three holder was it the outhouse
okay they didn't have one down at that
six because that six was just kind of
forming up
and uh so went there and dropped it off
and
it was uh that was your first combat
mission i guess by one of my first
missions yes i
was in a combat zone
so one of my later flights was about a
month later
was when uh we had one of our helos get
shot down
and this was at bc lake was down down
near where that six was done by son and
doc
and uh i was fine with a guy that was in
his last couple weeks in health three
and most of the time they're just doing
easy stuff we got this call the hilo was
down
we went in to get the people out
everybody was killed we
it was in the kind of a swamp area we
were able to get one of the bodies out
and we were at the whole this time we're
taking fire and i was shooting an m16
out of the
and i was a co-pilot i'm shooting
outside he finally gets one body
when we get out some cobras came unable
to get us out then they brought in some
uh vel4 the black ponies and they kind
of cleared the area and then they were
able to secure it
and get them out then the next day but
when we get back and landed
probably a foot behind where i was
sitting there was a round of five rounds
right behind where i was sitting so that
was my very first combat
that you'll hear about bc late what was
that date john
that was uh september 15th
big it's a major major
major operation uh
we lost four sea wolves that day off
from that six
yeah so then two weeks later i was
assigned to death six was one of the
replacement pilots
so it was funny i first i take the
three-holder down there
then they got this mission where they
lost some of the pilots and then i'm
i am assigned to debt six so i was like
destined
to be there and you said to them
i was the guy that brought you your
first three-holer
i showed up and i said i brought your
three-holder i'm john furrier
oh okay come on and so we were there
and actually son and doc got blown up so
we want to go to that story
on the 20th of october i got there the
8th of october
and we got mortared and the sonnen dock
was on the river
and we had we didn't have any perimeter
around where the helo pad was
but they had all the barges and that for
the swift boats
so all the swift boats were down there
big barges with fuel and everything was
about
you know 20 30 you know a couple hundred
feet from where the
heel pad was and one night you can it's
very distinct sound when you've got the
incoming
so you we heard the incoming ran to the
bunkers
it was late early evening and i was
actually reading catch 22. it was about
halfway through it
i still have i haven't still haven't
finished that's ironic yeah exactly
so there was a little lull in the action
we ran to the and i was on
flight status and i ran to the helos we
got airborne
and we flew the rest of the night and we
caught then health we scrambled that one
they were just done i was there liver
and earl and carl
we flew all night long just putting in
strike after strike going back rearing
refuel
finally in the morning we kind of got it
secured we went back and landed on the
pad
and they had come in and ransacked their
shacks and everything
we wanted to make sure you get the see
if the people were still in the bunker
they actually got into the barges and
got on smith boats and got out
to sea so everybody i think there was
only one person that was killed that was
on one of the barges
but halfway through the night they
finally hit the fuel barge
you see this huge fireball come up and
you could see it from down
where that one was which was you know
probably 50 clicks away or so
and uh easy to navigate there look at a
big flight yeah
and then the next day we found out there
was five rockets pointed
at the helos because of your most
vulnerable just as you're starting to
lift off and for some reason he messed
up they didn't work but they didn't go
off and we found out afterwards
we were first detachment to ever take
off during a mortar attack
and make it another record
yeah and so then so now and now did you
ever start to feel like you had some
kind of black cloud over your head
because right now we got rounds hitting
behind you replacing the guys that were
killed you got the
first person to take off during the war
this is only in the first two months
or three months and uh no wonder you
didn't finish reading catch 22 because
you realized you were freaking crazy
yeah for sure
but the thing is and we had carl and i
were talking about this the other day
says you know we were there to do a job
and do a mission
so you never thought about those things
you never thought about
the negative you know what could happen
you may be years later think
boy you had some close calls and we did
but not when it was happening when you
were it's like the earth you know when
they say the pilots are always so calm
you're always flying the airplane and
that's all you're focused on
is to fly the airplane with the engines
go out or that is it
why aren't they screaming or anything
because they're focused on doing their
job which is to fly the plane safely and
land it
how well did you guys feel you were
trained when you showed up there
highly trained i i think we were some of
the better pilots
and uh because we're very trained and
we've done this a million times and
then planning combat it was a little
more intense and we're you're focused on
your job
i i think the navy does a great job of
training their pilots
you know just doing the carolinas was a
piece of cake i said what's so hard
about this course we did it on a
beautiful day
calm seas but we had shot you know
probably a thousand approaches simulated
at land
so you get out to sea and it wasn't it
was nothing hard about it at all
of course at night in rough seas that's
a different story but
the hal three had nine detachments
in throughout the mekong delta
strategically placed
all the way from cambodian border down
to where i was
down in the lower kamal peninsula
and if you were fly if you got in
trouble at night you needed a matter
back at night
or an advanced tactical support base an
atsb kind of a
triangle shape and they got concertina
all around it and
they got hit all the time at night they
scrambled the sea wolves
and we would fly we were all weather
pilots
uh in those days yeah and most of the
army guys were not all weather pilots
they were
vlf vfr daylight pods not all of them
most of them
i was gonna say by all weather that
includes night time
night time and rain every monsoon season
you can barely see in front of your face
we're flying instruments in an old uh-1b
but we were all
instrument trained and we were heavily
instrument trained
after we got our through our primary
training and t28 we had instrument
training there
we went through another squadron vt6
nothing but instrument training
so we got all we got transitioned to the
aircraft
precision and acrobatics and then we got
over to do instruments and they did
instruments again and then went to do
fclps field
landing carrier practice for a lot of
them before you go hit the boat
in those days every naval aviator had
wings on
was the carrier qualified not anymore
we're saving money now so not anymore
and and obviously the army's just not
even landing on carriers at all
and and you don't i mean just in the
regular navy
the you got to fly a helicopter to do a
re to do a resupply at sea
and there's that deck's moving and you
got to do all weather anyways and
there's no horizon half the time and
everything else whereas
right you don't necessarily have to
contend with that in some of the other
services
it was always interesting to me when an
air cav package would come down to
where i was solid anchor sea float but
solid anchor when we had the runway
they would come and get there by nine
and they usually leave by five
got to get back and
when it gets dark you know okay uh
but to be fair when you mentioned song
and doc i had a memory as i was a
co-pilot in those days
and i was co-pilot for
to go unnamed an onc
and we usually flew at 800 feet
and he had to be 1200 feet that night i
said sir we're getting nosebleeds up
here we
our rockets are burning out before they
hit the ground
but anyway that's what song and doc
reminds me of it
so after that they brought in llst and
we did
we flew off an lst the rest of the time
that we're down here at sun and dark
after that so that that base got kind of
overrun then mm-hmm
yeah but they got it secure and they
still kept the the ship boats there and
everything
but they did overrun that night yeah
they did they did
and then they left i'm assuming they
left well we secured the area
we got the area secured again and we
went back in
but then they moved the helo pads well
we didn't kick the hello pad
they brought in an lst and we flew off
the lst the rest of the time
so so going back to showing up you show
up there you feel like you you're saying
you were
well trained and then what was the kind
of on-the-job
training procedure to get you guys where
you know you start you start off as a
co-pilot every time is every new guy
starting off as a co-pilot yes
we didn't have enough time your minimum
time for aircraft commander
was 500 total flight hours most of us
showed up out of training command
with 250 260 270. so you transition
in any squadron or navy when you get
there new you have to transition to the
type you go through what's called a rag
replacement a lot of acronyms as you
know replacement air group and so
you go to the rag set it up on all the
systems
fly the airplane and you're a co-pilot
when you have enough time
and you qualify you become aircraft
commander and with
hal three uh once
you show the capability to manage and
control
two aircraft and tactically be more
knowledgeable you become a fire team
leader
ftl another acronym so john was an mtl
yeah most of us were that yeah and then
what at what point
did you realize who you who you were
supporting when you saw that when you
saw the eight millimeter home movies was
he saying hey we're supporting the seal
teams over there and let me tell you
what the seal teams are
yeah he did and i never heard of a seal
i had no idea what a seal was
and i forgot what it was and i had to
ask him the next day what did you say
they were
and he said well they're like like
frogman i said yeah i know what
movies in the world were too i knew what
frogmen were and he said well they've
evolved from that from udt they're still
at udt but
they're and then that was 1968 the seals
hadn't been around a long time
as seals and uh yeah
and i uh remember going just
first of all sea float was a bunch of
barges tied together
and and there in the in the uh the bot
the bode river i think it was and
squamous peninsula
and uh it was great because they had two
seal platoons there we lived on these
barges
yet the the johns were you the river was
rushing down below
this way at morning and this way in the
afternoon
and all night long you couldn't sleep at
first when your new guy because
they're setting off concussion grenades
all night and the next morning
many mornings there'd be a sapper that
was trying to get there to blow the
place up
laying up they go over on the bank
blowed it up in the sun you know
and uh and a couple times they got
sappers on the boat but they got them
the seals got them before
they did any damage but it's amazing
uh the perseverance of some of those
characters i think
the primary mission was were there we
were the close air support for the swift
balls going up now in the canals
and if you ever go i've gone to places
and
talked to somebody and he was on the
ship post and he found out i was in hell
free and
he's buying me beers rest tonight so
they the swift boat guys really and the
seals as well
supported the sea wolves oh yeah
it's it's a legendary to to make sure
you give nothing but full respect to the
sea wolves when you're in the seal teams
for sure
uh so what's that what's a normal
mission look like how are you getting
the tasking
what are you are you are you meeting
with guys beforehand are you meeting
with the seal platoons and going over
hey here's where we want to get dropped
off
well how's that what does that look like
well carl couldn't speak to that cause
he had
he was with the seals on debt six we
didn't have any seals with us
we just had the swift boats and there
wasn't a lot of coordination with the
swift boats except when they got in
trouble
they called us up and scrambled us for
for close air support when they got into
trouble
but the seals those missions were
coordinated and i'll let carl speak to
that
they had many types of missions as you
know
jocko they uh and and many times they
would just be advising us look we're
gonna
go in at night and we're gonna go buy a
boat you know they've got a kit carson
scout that's going to lead him in
intelligence says xyz is here and they
would let us
you know where they're going to be and
then coordinates of where they're going
to be
and and uh and i'll tell a story here
about john sandoz
i'll use your name john and an
outstanding officer and the good news on
him is he operated
often and heavy and nightly it seemed
like
i don't think he got it there was one
purple heart in his group but he was a
heavy
operator and hats off to him on that one
so but he
did a night operation one night he let
us know where he's going to be in
and i was we were on brady five the
scramble aircraft were all
our gear is all in we've done all the
checks we've cranked it once it's ready
to go and you
literally hop in there and you're
airborne and like
you know i've heard term three minutes
we made we got off a lot quicker than
three minutes lots of times
and we got airborne and it was
black literally black well with
pre-brief john we gave john
uh what the strobe what was the strobe
called that we had john that we carried
the little strobes that it had a guard
around it and it was
oh a directional strobe yeah it was a
good and he had one
and he had a prick 90 radio of mine that
i gave him
because it was small and it was easy to
operate
and so john himself
tough seal he's out there and the enemy
is over here and
freedom's over here and john is between
both of them and he's going to defend
and he's out there uh see wolf 1-3 uh
uh put some fire in uh northeast about
three
about uh uh zero three
zero and just walk it in and i'll tell
you
when to stop okay so we we i rolled in
and started laying rockets in
and it was hilarious he goes okay a
little closer uh a little
closer uh and his voice starts racing a
little bit closer
last closer now and i could hear
i could hear rockets going off in the
background
and i was i hear i am safe and sound at
800 feet or whatever i was 600 feet
and it was hilarious and i never let him
forget that
ever so when you're flying at
i mean it's really uh how black it can
be
at night like it can be so dark outside
so when it's that dark you're just
flying pure instruments
you're just looking at yours you're not
even looking out outside because there's
nothing to see
unless you're looking at fire coming up
at you okay that
in something then it's real bright
sometimes you get lucky
and there's a moon out and there's a
moon out then you get flashes of light
off the squigglies and rivers and
streams and yeah
and but yeah there's nights out there
when you're like this and that's when
you have to have a co-pilot who knows
what he's doing
who can navigate because you're busy as
hell keeping that thing on altitude on
heading and realize you've got a wingman
who's got to have discipline too he's
got to know the heading you're on and
out you've got any collision like top
and bottom so you can keep track of each
other but it's
uh it can get hairy out there at night
and it's uh
you know some guys you look over one
time i mentioned earl shot's name world
was
co-pilot in mind many times good guy but
he was over there like this he got the
leans
pretty bad because the semi-circle
canals kind of getting messed up and you
think
you're level but you're not when you
start when you start getting vertigo
he's over there like this i said okay or
it was just
we weren't in combat or anything we were
just flying he's over there leaning
sideways i said okay earl you got he
himself oh that's okay
no errol you got it and i'm over there
laughing the crew's laughing but
uh earl excellent pilot but once in a
while you can get them like that but uh
no it is dark and it's like
um how do you say the inside of
somebody's rectum how do you say that
nicely
i think you just did it yeah okay
but but once again if you do it enough
you you know how to do it and
you're comfortable doing it so what were
the swift let's talk about the swift
boat operations because those guys were
pushing up and pushing the envelope into
enemy territory
what what was that op tempo like well
they're scrambling to go to where the
coordinates were then you were just
putting in fire
and once again you were they would say
shoot right over our heads and say well
why don't you
pull back a little bit just to make sure
but
those would get intense and i think i
think you saw quite a bit of that when
you did
the documentary on scramble of sea
wolves and that's what it was like we
were out there supporting them
putting in close fire to them just so
they could get
back out of that situation and you
mentioned john you mentioned the
the world war ii attitude when it comes
to
flying and fighting and i mean i i
get that but can you can you talk a
little bit more about i know that
you the way you all felt about a your
gunners the guys that were on your birds
but also your maintenance crews that
were
keeping your birds up and running and
using beer cans to patch them up and
whatever else so that's that that's sort
of the world war two mentality that
you're talking about where
you said there were rules but but you
had to do the mission
right and i think that's was part of it
every it was a
team effort so you talk about that the
gunners and the maintenance people
we all worked very well together we all
had our part to do
and it was all coordinated and it all
came together
and we had to get to make the gunners do
their job the maintenance people
and it just it was a team effort and
everybody supported the team
and all had the same mission to do
even though it was a different part it's
like a football team you know you've got
your job to do
and it doesn't work unless you're doing
your part of the job
and that's what we did it just
worked i was going to say and you ought
to know jacko is that
a fire team and most attachments would
come on
for 24 on 24 off for 24 on you're on
for scrambles you get your meals and you
get some rest when you can
but you're on duty from noon to noon
usually we did it
but wherever but and when you're and
anything that happened during that time
uh
your your cruise at the radio you're all
briefed and by briefed
you go down to what we call toc with the
army the
the operation center we know where are
their
where their artillery is at we know
where the units all the units are
we know what their radio frequencies are
we know what the planned
operations are we have a general idea
where the bad guys are but most of the
time
when we weren't actually involved in a
combat operation
we'd be patrolling and basically looking
for trouble that's what we always did
and we'd usually find it and uh
sometimes people get
it never i can't i have a hard time
thinking about a flight that i was on
that we didn't get shot at i i'm sure
there were some but it was rare
that we didn't get shot at and we wanted
him to shoot at us because we could
shoot back we could know where they were
didn't have to call for a clearance they
shot at you could just be in the fire
in my aorta down at dead one before i
went to that job six was john
and the ao we had was literally a free
fire zone
we could shoot any eligible aged
male now we didn't we were that's not
how we operated you don't go
we didn't go blowing up hooches and
shooting randomly and
cheated we didn't shoot a dam but we
didn't do that honestly
ever i mean you do that on somebody's
crew and you're going to get your butt
kicked off and back to
back to home garden heartbeat we were
professional but
elizabeth male could be that we just we
might just take his
sam pound out under him you know because
he's in the wrong area
we don't kill the guy but he's swimming
and
uh if it's uh
a guy who gets stupid and starts
shooting back well then we erase that
guy
and but again we were pre-brief we knew
where everything was what was going on
and uh more often than not we could
brief
toc as well as they could bring we get
different frequencies
from them but the intel we could feed to
them
we knew what was going on everywhere so
in a 24 hour period where you're on so
you said you do 24 hour on and then 24
hour off
in the 24 hour period that you're on how
much time are you in the air
depends on what kind of operation you
have but
i honestly i flew a lot
because i was in the opinion the more
airborne i was the better pilot i was
the better my crew was
because everybody's doing their job they
loved it i loved it and to better renew
our area of operations
um i have uh many times flown
if you say every other day's 15 days um
i've flown many months for 100 to 130
hours a month
and during the day maybe eight to ten
hours it wasn't unusual
we were looking at your logbook today
and we flew together that first month
uh at definitely long yeah
all day long and everything that was our
job is to fly
you know sitting in the hooch we're not
doing our job
so we were out flying just even if it
was just training looking for
action or looking for something so when
your day off what are you doing you're
doing your job whether it's hops
or admin or maintenance or whatever your
job is or sleeping because you know the
next day you may not get any sleep
so you you sleep and
no it was we were jg's
and i remember i was getting a fitness
report debrief
from my own c very nice man i didn't
know what a fitness support i knew what
it was i saw it in class sometime
but but i barely know the fitness pro
wasn't and he was stroking me and i
didn't know it but he
he says now carl i know you really like
this mission you're really enjoying it
oh yeah sir i mean i was just
he says but the real navy's not like
this
you're not gonna go to a squadron and
have this much authority and
responsibility
i mean we're out there deciding who
lives and who dies
every day and we're trying to make the
right decision every day i think we did
so and he was right we got to lakehurst
and what was it like
i know it was so we were jg's and you're
a fire team leader
you're responsible for that whole flight
you're in charge of it
even if you got a lieutenant commander
sitting next to you you're the one
that's calling the shots as a jg
because you're in charge of it and that
was important i think
and i look at people say what's the best
period of your life some say oh it was
high school or college
i can honestly say the best period of my
life was the six years
i spent on active duty in the navy the
rent the friendships you make
during that period especially in combat
are so close
closer than any other friendships i have
so like carl and earl and
tim ziemer we were all there we've done
the same thing together
and we had a reunion what 10 years ago
now was
2009 at my house up 12 years ago 12
years ago he's not good at math and
uh and carl well first of all i invited
earl and his wife up to chicago because
his wife had never been to chicago so
i'll come up we'll show you
this big city and the bright lights and
everything and then an
hour later i get a call from carl says
well thanks for inviting me because i
early talk to him in the meantime and i
said well carl you've been here before
you're always welcome
the next thing i know i had my house
full of people coming up for a reunion
we had 14 guys showed up yeah
this is on the 4th of july far's got
free food and booze
oh yeah so we've got a big tent put it
up in the backyard and everything and we
had this
little reunion and john santos we always
had a seal that every one of our
unions were very small it was just a
small group of people that were together
what i found interesting about the first
time that we did it some of these people
i hadn't seen in
40 years and so where you started was a
common denominator was vietnam
remember this mission remember that guy
remember that incident
by the end of the evening it was like we
just seen him last weekend
i was amazed at how fast you could catch
up with somebody
you should do a study on that well it's
like your family you know
these guys know all your crap and they
still like you
and you they know you on bad days and
good days and i'm going to tell the
story
it's it's one of those this this ain't
no no but it's true
i he talked about being
when you're in charge of a fire team
you're in charge and
rank matters but rank in the cockpit
goes away you may say sir but you're in
charge of the airplane your co-pilot's
the captain okay captain sit there don't
touch anything
that you're in charge and and it's navy
regs that
your your aircraft cannot be
commandeered by some guy on the ground
saying fly over here and do this
no the only person that can dominate
kendama your commandeer your aircraft
your aircraft commander is a flag
officer a line officer in your
back sitting in a seat is the only guy
that can override
an aircraft commander flag ops so
that in mind one night at that one
captain
martin twice great guy he's passed on
now he was our seal he came to flag that
one
and you know he's you start flying and
you don't mean it
in a bad way but you get your chin out
and your chest out
and you're aggressive and you and no bs
you can laugh and have
fun but the mission's serious
there's no screwing around so captain
troy wanted to go on a combat flight so
he came down and
and he was my co-pilot of course i sat
in the left seat and respectfully let
him have the right
which aircraft commander and a
helicopter my wingmen
was two other guys i won't use their
names but lieutenant commander
and a lieutenant and i'm a jg very
very very green jay so you're the junior
guy in rank but you're the
but you're the first team leader got it
and we're down there at toc and there
was this army guy
who i didn't like anyway he was a
captain he didn't like me
he was just he was just too good he
could shoot goody two shoes and didn't
know squat what he was talking about so
he's up there
and he's briefing those eagles on
captain dwight he kept
you know kissing up and i just said stop
stop
brief me this is not the army this is
the navy
the navy it has nothing to do with rank
it's who's the smartest guy
here and on this mission i'm the
smartest guy here
brief me captain dwight shook his
look down carl he was so nice to me
he should have slapped me but he didn't
do that and that army guy
was mad but nothing he could do about it
but that's
kind of how it is the aircraft commander
is
the ultimate it's like the captain of a
ship abuse
what you say goes and your job is to do
the right thing
i want i want to try and get a little
bit better feel for the
some of the operations and i mean just
the the first operation that you
were talking about going to the vc lake
and you're going to recover a helicopter
like talk us through from you get the
call
to you you're leaving the scene and you
got the
body recovered was it you know you're
sitting in your
you're sitting in the in the in the
ready room and all of a sudden the call
comes in
what does that look like no i was on a
fam flight so we were out flying
just in the general area and we get this
call that the gilo
was down we got the coordinates and we
were close to the coordinates
so we were there fairly quickly so we
got in
and you have are you always you're
always fine with a section of birds of
two birds you're always flying together
this is this
was a single bird okay because it was a
fit it was a well you
was john was new in the country and you
were flying an admin flight right
yes you were flying a slick flashlight
so flying a circle
you still had you still had door gunners
you still had the crew in the back
but you might fly alone if you're doing
an admin mission you might fight with
just one bird
like when you hoisted the three-holer
down it was just a single fight
that's right because you weren't you
weren't looking to be in
you know a mission a combat mission per
se just trying to get familiar with the
error
but if something happens you got to
respond to it and we didn't this bill
belts was it was his last week in
country and he flew in and
tried to get these guys out as best we
could and the
so what else was your was your he was
the the
helicopter commander pilot the one that
went down or the one that you were in
the one i was in okay so the one thing
it's his last week in country
last week in country he's getting ready
to go home and everything but he was
showing me around the area stuff is as a
new pilot
and then we get this call and it heals
down respond to it
and the crewmen in the back once we got
down
low they got they jumped out how long
did it take you to get to
to find them to find the down hilo those
minutes you have coordinates yeah you
can see smoke it's
well we wouldn't there wasn't any smoke
or anything but it was down it was a
kind of swampy area so there wasn't any
fire
but uh we were close to the area they
gave us accordances which
we're kind of right there so we were
there within i want to say we're
you know five ten minutes after within
five minutes
easy and so we just flew in
and uh you know then we there wasn't any
fire at times so we're down there
the crew jumps out to try and get the
bodies out but they were kind of the
hill was turned in they were kind of
pinned under it
they were only get able to get one body
out we got that in the heel in the
meantime we started taking fire
from the tree line and that's when i was
shooting the m16
at the tree line and then we got enough
then we got the body in and then we just
then some cobras came because they had
heard about the coordinates
and then they covered us as we came out
let me ask you john where's on the fly
here
two guys from debt one we were down to
one bird because
every hundred hours we had to get a new
aircraft from maintenance
the major main was done in ben tui so we
would do the oil changes and filter
changes and so forth but they did all
the heavy stuff
but two guys from debt one were mike
legal
i'll give him rich lambert they came up
and they got shot down that day too
were they already shot down when you got
there or you got their first probably
didn't you i think we got that first you
got their first
they came in scrambled up went in and
they had a gunship
and uh the bad guys i think had a 51
caliber
and they were knocking them out of the
air it was like a setup
it was like an ambush because once the
first one come down
they know we're going to try and come
and get people out so they kind of
you were lucky you guys weren't shut
down yeah very lucky
when uh when when you're flying and and
carl you mentioned that
you can't even remember operations where
you didn't take fire
how often is your aircraft getting hit
you know that's you post flight really
heavily when you get back and you can
you know
when you're when you're a new guy you
can't hear
certain things but when you're got
experience
you can hear gunfire you can hear it
from a from 800 feet
you can hear it you can dance or hear it
when you're breaking off target at 200
feet but
uh
uh back on but anyway the bottom line is
is that uh
uh we would get back on post flight and
uh more often than not
um and we by the way we've we found uh
we would find uh
the seals would bring in intel stuff and
it would be
a drawing of a helicopter and in
vietnamese
telling the bad guys where to aim so
they could hit the aircraft
because most of the time they'd shoot at
us and hit the tail section
most all of my hits not all of them but
most of them were aft
of the cabin there were some in the
cabin and they were uncomfortable and
sometimes
i know john got a purple heart and you
can tell that story
and i got one earl got one done i mean
it's no big deal i mean you get it
because you got
shot and it's not nothing necessarily
heroic people think a big
a purple heart's a big deal it's not a
big deal uh i'd give mine to anybody
wants it if i can have the hole back
period but so since you brought the
topic up uh this is something yeah let's
let's let's talk about it and i talk
about this all the time
and uh so we carl was on debt six at
that point
and we were out and that one only had
one of their birds say one in
maintenance so
we went down to debt one and we formed a
three-plane formation
and so i was a pilot of one carl was a
pilot oneness earl shot
was a pilot of the third so we went out
took some fire
found a target and i'm not sure who was
first one to end i think
me you he forgot to add it was a heavy
fire team
and i was a fire team leader so kyle
those two guys are doing
everything i ask them to do most of the
time so carl's the first
so heavy fire team means you got three
birds three birds okay
so kyle is the first one in and you're
going in to do what what are you going
to do
putting a strike in so far when you say
putting a strike in
meaning you're going to lay fire down
rockets
is is it close air support necessarily
or is it
just taking some ground fire and we're
going to put it out basically
and so you're rolling in and then carl
was the first one in earl was the second
one and so
carl peels off and earl's putting down
fire so as he's peeling off that's when
the plane's supposed to be turned
the second plane is supposed to put down
on fire so earl put on fire
by that time carl's supposed to come
around then when earl comes off to
target
i'm putting fire down i came off the
target and that's when i got hit
and so so we argued today i said carl
you didn't cover me coming off target
and he says well you are out of position
i said i wasn't out of position you were
out of position
so i got hit so where did you get hit i
got hit in the foot
so the round came up and knocked the
tips of my two
toes off tips of my toes off on my right
foot
and then you saw the scramble of sea
wolves my gunner that day
was he got it at the same time kid he
was a
kid uh and the scramble of sea wolves at
the end
where the round came up cut his mic cord
came out dotted his helmet and dotted
the eye on kid written on the back of
his helmet it was in the movie
it was in the movie yeah and it cut the
back of his neck like you cut it with a
knife
yeah and how's that so so he gets it i
look back and i'm trying to call him and
he's not responding i look back
and all i see is blood like oh geez he
gives me a thumbs up
a big smile and starts shooting again
and the round just
you cut the mic cord just graze the back
of his neck and of course when you cut
your
neck or head and it just bleeds like
crazy and then
uh so then we go back land carl comes
over
picks me up and carries me into the
infirmary
the real story should we hear the real
story
well that's so and to this day we argue
who's out of position but we're the best
of friends
it's interesting that's like in a sealed
platoon
that's that's one of the basic maneuvers
we do is like one person shooting as
that person rolls out there's someone
that's picking up fire right behind him
as that person rolls out there's someone
picking up the fire right here that's
the way it's supposed to be
carl that's the way it's supposed to be
in a racetrack
in a wrist strike pattern this veteran
at that time i probably had
800 missions and far it barely knows how
to pre-flight
yeah he's in position and i'm not but
what's funny is we got back
and and i didn't know that purington was
wounded and we got back and landed
and uh john was oh
oh i thought my god he's he probably has
a body shot checked his body
checked the blood and i couldn't find
any blood anywhere
i'm looking nothing not he's dry i'm
thinking
and i picked him up and gently carried
him
600 yards down to infirmary the length
of the base
he's moaning the whole way meantime
purington's bleeding
and he's walking chatting the whole time
but john's
john's moon moaning not that he must
have a brain wound i can't see or
something
and so let's just see what i put up all
the time
and we get down there he takes his boot
off
and he shot in the big toe so earl comes
a little toes
earl calls you earl calls him nine toes
that's his name
so then i get medevaced up to ventui to
the third surge which is the army
hospital up there
and i obviously wasn't that badly
wounded and they put me in the back
room and that night everybody came over
to see me i had a little
nightstand table i must have had 30
scotching waters on that little table
because everybody brought me a drink
do you save your boots the boots i do i
do and i was very lucky the doctor said
because it came it was
he had steel toe boots but he came up to
the bottom and he said
just missed a steel toe if it hit the
seal toe that would ricochet around
in it taking all your toes out john has
the boot
on a nice little stand in his living
room where there's a sprinkler around it
and music and so forth
he's got a plaque there but i do and i
have
actually i have the round that came up
okay
around from he's got around so
it came up with my foot and then hit me
on the side of the leg
and i didn't know you can only feel one
pain at a time it
will hit me on the sideline when i was
getting out of the helo i saw this round
down by the collective so i picked it up
and put in my pocket
was that two days later i was getting
out of bed and i bumped my knee
and i go geez that really hurts and i
had a big welt about this big around
on the inside of my thigh there and so
you can only feel one pain i just feel
my toes at the time a couple days later
i was feeling the other one
but that was around who was the ceo then
oh also the changed command that day i
got you out was a change of command
and captain bergstrom was taking over
from captain twice
and the tradition was that the first guy
that got shot the co had to buy him a
bottle of scotch
so he did it for a bottle of scotch so
there's a we had an officer's meeting i
don't know
a month later or something like that and
sure enough he gave me a bottle of
scotch
brought it back to that and shared it
with the with the team
was it cheap i can't remember i don't
know drew overs or something like that
so what about you carl when did you get
shot what happened to you oh earl and i
were together and we just
we just uh it was minor it was minor
stuff but i believe a lot i used uh
we took a round through the cockpit what
was what was the operation
you know actually we were just on a
patrol we weren't actually even put in a
strike you could take a round randomly
and it happened one time when we were
taking a
a platoon to insert them the
radioman got shot on the way in with
one of richard's guys tom richards guys
but
we just took a random around as i recall
and uh
and earl and i took both took flack on
the face where it bounced off
of the center divider and the windscreen
so we got glass in our face and
metal in our face and it looked pretty
bad until we shaved the beard and
actually wasn't bad at all
it was minor so i didn't limp anywhere i
didn't have to be carried down to
third to third search search nobody
bought me booze at all
nobody cared you know and i didn't care
but when they treat you
and you're wounded and they treat you
and they stitch you or whatever
you get a purple heart that's what uh
the honorable john kerry figured out it
hurt morgan sewing up and it did get in
shot
because they had to pull the skin around
my toes and stuff and i had to soak my
foot for about a week to make sure
there's no infection and everything
we gave him tons of grief over that and
we love john he's a great guy one of the
best guys i know
and a gentleman i don't have many guys i
can call gentlemen that i know
at least not sea wolves anyway but i was
back flying in two weeks
and at what point so what point did you
guys link up and start we
were you at the same debt was that debt
six you said
yes and what caused that what caused you
two to be to start working together
what had happened well i i was a very
experienced fire team leader and what
they do
is they when you first get to hal 3 in
those days you had a
month or two in the home guard and you
kind of transitioned
you already transitioned to the h1
because you flew the h-1 in flight
school
but you transition to the mission and
build your time get to know the area of
operations you fly to every debt
taking mail and parts and people and
that month or two you do that and then
your detachment
you make aircraft commander and then you
make fire team leader
and after a period of time before you go
home they bring you back in you fly
at home guard again for a couple of
months as the aircraft commander like
bill belts did for you
when you were when he went to vc lake
and so
the executive officer
was one to bring me back to do that and
i said
it was march and i said hey i got two
months march and april
i i don't want to go back i'd i'm just
getting good at this leave me alone
and so i whined and whined and whined
and finally he demoted me he took me to
took me to death sex pardon me so
they didn't have a fire team leader uh
one and got killed
and one had uh reached the end of his
tour
and so um
they had some really really good
aircraft commanders and you you were a
co-pilot i first got there i think and
you became maybe you were an aircraft
commander
okay well there were there were three or
four or five good guys and
i'll name them john farr john barnes uh
mack him and paul waters
who did i miss that's it
hey mack him with did i miss a mac no he
said meg
and uh super guys and the exo said go
get those those guys are all just
they need a little leadership they need
a little experience
and uh go do it if you gotta
go and see
not so much he had a bad case of
lieutenant commander
which is do nothing i i tried to figure
out when he went to the navy i've tried
to avoid lieutenant commander
if i could go from lieutenant to
commander i've been very happy
but anyway so i sort of
had to be me and a little put my chin
out and chest out and have these
these great guys that uh took about uh
30 minutes to fire up and get going and
all of a sudden we were flying all day
every day
like we're supposed to not sitting back
at the boat waiting for meals
and then what's on at the movie we don't
give damn once in a movie we're going to
fly it
period that's what you do that's how you
know you're ao
that's how you support the people out
there in the boats and that's how it
happens
if somebody gets shot down you're right
there on the spot
that's what we do are you guys flying
the same
helicopter all the time do you have a
particular one
or you just whichever one's ready well
whichever
one is ready and able to fly and so you
got them on debt the two you have on
debt
you're flying nose obviously and then
you have to take up what you know once a
month or
so many hours to do the annual
maintenance on it then get another one
back
how much difference is there between you
know this one and that one
none you know physically flying they're
all the same just like driving a car you
just you know what to do they're all
you know i was in our training squadron
with earl and bt-3
after our helicopter we went back
fix-wing for a while
and i remember guys fighting over a
aircraft that was smoother and it was a
bravo model instead of a charter mile
and it's faster and
i mean who gives a crap just go fly you
know
and that's what we did we didn't we
didn't have our name on the aircraft
that's top gun crap you know we didn't
put you i
you know i i'll tell a joke i when i
became maintenance officer vt3 i was a
boot lieutenant commander unfortunately
and we had 400 airplanes and we were
starting to downsize
taking these old charlie models that
were made for carrier landings and they
were all beat up from hard landings
and they were towing them over and
scrapping them well my assistant
maintenance officer is a guy named russ
combs great guy and he's
he's boss you want me you're my new boss
you're going
to put your name on one of these
airplanes i said you put my name on
those airplanes
combs and i will break every bone in
your body don't you
do it well so one day i get
i came back from a flight and he said i
got your plane parked up in front sir
did you see it i said
where i go out and all the lion guys
around laughing
he took one of those old charlie miles
scraped off the exhaust
painted lieutenant commander cd nelson
rotor head
on it and old charlie mall right there
in front and it was a big haha
and so they're going to take it the main
side and just scrap it anyway so
who cares well pretty soon i get a phone
call from a guy saying hey i was just in
the navy leaf museum and your airplane's
in there
they took that plane just at random and
reworked that charlie model and put it
in the museum
and they left my name on it the museum
down in pensacola yeah and but i think
it's gone i couldn't find it last time
and thank god for that but uh anyway
no we didn't what we didn't care what we
flew we were going flying
all the same let tom cruise get his name
on something we did have nicknames for
each other and
i can't tell you john's real nickname
because his family's going to see this
i would see wolf68 there you go that
sounds like the pg version so you talk
about the last weeks in the
squadron and people would just come up
and kind of
chill out the last two weeks before they
left and i actually flew
the last two weeks that i was in the
squadron
the cia had sold something on the black
market and they
this was done in human force there was
some kind of communication center in the
human force and they couldn't quite
figure out was what it was or where it
was
so they sold something on the black
market they wouldn't tell us what it was
but they knew
it would end up to this headquarter area
and so they had they picked a a signal
or a
frequency that wasn't being used by any
other friendlies in the area
put that in homemade device and we wish
to follow it
and we did this for 10 days and then
this went on a site and i just go slow
and
go a couple hundred miles and spend the
night go a little further spend the
night and
finally got to an area oh we were
getting a stray signal we never got a
real strong
signal so we talked and says one night
we just
followed the signal back and it flew
over this church
and the needle just did a 180. so he
went back told the seals
about this and they went and raided that
church
and they found a huge communication
center in the basement of the church
so once they knocked that out we had
this real strong signal
so we flew it everybody says i hope this
guy gets the place before i have to
leave country
so the last day i was in country
we finally decided well this is it
hadn't moved for three or four days it
must be the place it wasn't exactly
where they thought it was but it must be
the place
so we were to fly in throughout smokes
and they had a couple flights of f-4s
off the coast so we went in 100 feet
throw the smokes out pulled back and
that was the best air show ever seen in
my life and that forest came in just
bombed down the place and so then i flew
back to bentui
literally jumped out of one helo they
had my bag packed and another hill
jumped in another hill through the
saigon the next day i flew home
well i flew a mission my last day in
country
when you guys were there you know like
um when we
like my generation looks looks at the
vietnam war
and the late 60s early 70s you know it's
all this
uh protesters and hippies and and
controversy about being in vietnam how
much of that stuff did you guys actually
experience or think about when you were
over there
i didn't think about it at all not at
all i
we're doing our job doing our mission we
didn't think about what's going on back
in the states to be honest with you at
least for my part
i remember going to r r i didn't go to r
r until like in my 11th month cause i
won
i didn't want to miss out on flying
that's terrible i'm awful flight hog
that's what they
used to call me and that was a nice name
they called me but
we got i remember we're flying over to
honolulu
i'm going to meet my wife my then wife
then she liked me then
and see girls i mentioned your mom and
so um
guys are all chatty and all excited and
we get on this old bus and we're going
they're taking us to fort gerusi there
on on waikiki and all the women are all
lined up and
as we drive through ala moana drive past
the park and everything as we're going
to
fort derussy you could hear a pin drop
on that bus
all that chatter all of a sudden it died
and guys were all
a gape because women
weren't wearing bras we've never seen
that
and men had a ponytail longer than mine
and they looked funny they had beards
and
they were funny tie-dye-ty stuff i'd
never seen so in 10 months
i didn't recognize where i honestly i
was in shock and i also
remember i don't know what the hell i
was doing but we went to a movie
in honolulu one of the times and
it was the movie version of mash
okay and i was so offended
by the disrespect for officers in the
military
i got them walked out in about 10
minutes wouldn't stay
it's funny how are you so offended and
and then
when you mention up i remember going in
and this is 1970 going into leaving me
saying goodbye to people
and they're all gung-ho rah-rah but when
i came back
same guys were was it really bad
no oh gee kill babies over there
no but some of that stuff and i even
50 years later in my living room one of
my relatives asked told me
gee carl i didn't know you're in vietnam
yeah
oh well were you what's your used term
what term did she use
made a derogatory term she said and uh
whatever it was
were you disappointed or were you
ashamed or whatever she said
i said no matter of fact i wasn't my
son-in-law is giving me the cut sign
because it's his step on and he doesn't
want me to blow her away with
with my fire and fury but i didn't i
restrained
and i and i said matter of fact
i don't know anybody that i serve with
who feels that way matter of fact
and this is interesting guy friends of
mine that
didn't serve and didn't go to vietnam
i've yet to meet one and talk to one
who's not sorry they didn't and i've yet
to meet one who served that was sorry
they did
so that's my little world i guess that's
the people i hang around i hang around
mostly good people so
did you see anything like that like that
john well no when i came home
i was welcomed home because you know
from a family perspective
i got to the house and you know my
parents picked me up at the airport and
i was in uniform
got back to house and they had a sign
it was a eight by four board
park aboard they had written on it
welcome home and they had
my sister had painted and she was an
artist the sea wolf
signia on this uh uh
was an eight by eight by four foot board
and so i was it was sit up in the front
yard hit it in the front yard
up welcome home john so uh
in my course my my dad being in the army
and his history was very supportive of
that
but i did have one incident where they
had me go on some recruit
recruiting duty when i first came back
for about two months and they
had to go down to the university of
illinois and we were down there for a
couple days doing some recruiting duty
not that we got a lot of people signed
up or anything
but i went to put my pants on one
morning the legs and my pants
just fell off so when i was there
apparently somebody had thrown some acid
or something on my uniform that was the
only incident i
i had with with that but other than not
recruiting very well or getting a lot of
people into the navy
at that time well what about uh you know
it's a question that comes up a lot
and i've uh working with draftees
and from what i've looked when i've
talked to vietnam vets
and when i read about them the the
common thread
is that people that were people that
were good leaders and took care of their
men they would either not know who the
draftees were
because they just they just were good um
or they liked the draftees and could
tell who they were but they
had no issues with them because the
draftees would say but they kind of had
to step
up and and the draft you say i don't
like that we were doing this and say
well how do you want to do it and they
would kind of engage them into the
into the planning and then get listen to
their input
and then you you can read some negative
opinions of the draftees when you get
someone that's
that you know it's almost like an excuse
well the draftees didn't want to do what
they needed to do
what did you guys did you guys notice
any difference between draftees and
and and guys that were uh i guess for
lack of a better term lifers
i don't think i did that i think if you
were drafted in it was
maybe a specific for the navy i think it
may be maybe a different situation
because most people they got drafted
went into the army
they were and i think the people that
ended up in the navy were more
volunteers
and wanted to be in the navy if they
were going to pick a service i want to
be in the navy or the air force i don't
want it i started to be in the army
got it if they're sea wolves they
volunteer and they volunteer to be sea
wolves
yes i read a book one time i had to give
a speech i was asked to
reluctantly of course i did to give a
speech on memorial day did you come out
of your shell for that
i did and so uh
there's a cemetery in a little town of
gridley california up north of
sacramento about an hour
and they've got a really a mini
arlington
in the back and i was really overcome it
was neat
didn't know this but i don't know how
they know but supposedly the first
sailor killed
in the pearl harbor attack was from
gridley california now i don't know how
they decided who got killed first
that configuration but they did and so
they built it around that
and they have a celebration every year
well i met their manager because
a friend of mine was on the board of
directors i thought the board of
directors of a cemetery what do you
fight over spots or i mean what do you
need a board for that for
a lottery for a plant plotter anyway
and i met her nice lady engaging she
says you know you served that's the way
i did
jesus we need a speaker
this was like november and i said when
she says oh in may
memorial day but yeah i mean
i'm best i was farming those days i was
raising olives
for olive oil 500 acres that's how to
stick your toe in the water
you're good toe and so so
i got this i got to say oh god how long
are me to talk she said
whatever you want i said realistically
she said 20 minutes i said okay and i
said
uh do you want to read this piece before
i give it because you know i don't want
to be cut no
she says whatever you want
so i started reading books and kind of
going through stuff and i read a book
that was pretty neat and well it was
well
um documented and well referenced at
all the pages and and it was written by
a guy named bg burkett
and the book is called uh stolen valor
and about guys who pretend to be a
ranked or not or pretend they serve and
they didn't and
it mentioned our friend former senator
and secretary of state john kerry and
other people like that
and it was really interesting book
because i learned a lot and what i
learned was
that if i ask you what percentage of men
volunteered for vietnam what would you
say
john down 10
76 according to this research okay
yeah a big number and a big number not
only volunteered
but but you know it was
a lot of shocking things and about drugs
and well you know people say gee you're
in vietnam you must have a problem with
drugs
i didn't smell marijuana until i was at
a john denver convert in 1975.
i had no i mean if somebody did drugs
like that
i swear i wouldn't know we were close we
lived side by side we're like a family
we'd have known i'll agree with it i had
no
none of the enlisted nobody did drugs i
never saw any of that
in vietnam might have been some of those
guys chasing women with
buying them tees and saigon i don't know
but we didn't have any women to chase
where i was and uh just a bunch of butt
ugly guys so
i think they may be part of that is
because of the squadron you know it's a
different level
you're in the navy the training and and
people who are selected to go
you were just quality people and they
were weren't into those things
so the gun the country changed
aquaculture because
that day i remember my opening line of
my speech on
and by the way i walked i went to thank
god i put a suit on but i went to give
that speech on memorial day in gridley
2005 i think was it year
i could my daughter's dropped me off and
i said i got to walk and do this saying
you know what to say
and i walked past this big hedge in this
big mini arlington they had 500 people
in there
and they had every miss whatever county
sing of the song and they had
a flyover from from the air base in
sacramento and
they had even had a guy from world war
one who could barely walk in his uniform
and uh
i mean and they had i don't know honor
guard there and she called it a
she called it a firearm squad but it was
an honor guard so
and i remember my opening line and i'll
end with that was
the last battle of the vietnam war
was fought and won by the swift boat
veterans against john kerry
and people got on their feet and clapped
that's what kind of crowd i had
how's that for changing the country
amazing so
that's coming a long way from 1970 right
that is that is definitely heading back
in the other direction for sure
you know before we uh i know i opened
talking about that operation
where you were where carl you were you
were supporting
uh zulu platoon what other
what do you remember about that day i
mean that had to be sort of
it sounds like that had to be one of the
more um
you know more i guess dramatic
operations that you supported
we had some we had with the
seal teams we had some exciting ones
most of them were at night but that was
a broad daylight one
and when uh the onc of zulu came to me
the night before
and we sat down and you mentioned about
communication we
we live we live within 50 75 yards of
those guys and so
yeah we'd pre-brief the night before and
talk about you know where they're going
and most of the time
you know they didn't wasn't daylight it
was a night op and we would
stand ready to scramble if they got in
trouble and
but this was going to be a daylight off
and he had intelligence about
some supplies or equipment or
ammo or something that was north of our
of our base probably you know maybe 50
clicks i'm not sure of 20 clicks
and uh we briefed it and what he was
going to do and
he had a had a sea lord slip coming ed
dyer was flying that as you mentioned
and
ed was a former fire team leader up at
det9 well experienced
understood fire team tactics and so
forth
and uh so
we briefed it and so forth and we took
off and uh and
my co-pilot my co-pilot was earl and he
was well experienced
ready earl was ready to be i think he
was about this far from
aircraft commander and obviously was a
very successful
fire team leader retired as a navy
captain hell of a guy
and uh but our but my wingman
um to go unnamed was questionable
uh but we put him with a nuke with a
newer co-pilot who was
a pretty solid guy so we always tried to
put a solid
co-pilot with a pilot maybe not all
pilots are actually
the bases like john but some guys there
are some guys who are good guys but they
you know
god didn't give them those skills so
that's the fact so
so i knew my wingman was questioned but
we briefed off the op and what we're
going to do we're going to escort this
slick in
and and uh and i would
i would lead we'd lead it into the lz
into the landing zone with i'd lead it
in and i decided
it was going to be a it was going to be
a break
left because i wanted the right door it
was mike dobson
gunner to be the outside of the circle
we would go down to
about 100 feet
or less and circle low orbit while the
seals exit
the slick and cover them we literally
lay cover fire down
not wait for any fire and uh and then
once they're all out and clear and
imposition
and the slick wanted to pull pitch and
he would call and warn me we would
escort him out
i'd lead him out the wing would follow
him out
well as i made my turn
and i'm looking across earl i made a i
made a left-hand turn so i'm looking
across my co-pilot
and i'm saying earl do you see sea wolf
whatever his number was i know his
number but i'm not saying it
no call him
stay on the radio find him meantime i
got a seal team on the ground
i've got to escort a slick out and my
wingman's missing
so he had to be shot down or
had a mechanical failure or something
but i ended up trying to raise him
earl's trying to raise them i'm
communicating with dyer
we get dyer out we get him we get him
over to a safety area
at altitude where he can orbit and wait
until we need them
because they got to come out sometime so
meantime we're calling for my wingman
he's not answering no answer
can't find him well then i get a call
from tom richards and
tom's on the ground and he said um
when you're flying over here did you did
you see you know after you put your
strike in you want to put a strike and i
put a strike and single ship
which is against squadron policy do a
single single ship strikes because
you know but i had no choice obviously
that guy's on the ground
and they were taking fire we were taking
fire on the way in and on the way out
so it was pretty hi they were they were
not happy folks on the ground there the
bad guys
so um tom asks you know do you see
anybody i said
after i put the strike and i said yeah i
got a i got
10 12 guys dead there we and
what else you see that says there was a
big dyke they were on it they were
on the dikes were kind of running uh
east west and they were flooded they
were little dikes and there was a great
big dike and beyond that a tree line
and that's where the fire was coming run
from from behind the big dike and the
tree line well we knocked out that big
dike pretty quickly
but the tree line we had a hard time
stopping the fire and we
we laced it pretty good i mean earl
walsh the minigun up and down
there many times but i'm i'm starting to
get concerned about conserving my ammo
and making sure of making sure it counts
and we've got to find michael but i
couldn't worry about those four guys
that were on my trail ship
and i lost them but i had six seals on
the ground
my own four guys and four guys on the
other airplane of dyers
so you know we got 14 guys i got to
worry about of my own
before i worry about four more
and all of a sudden uh and tom and i
were talking and all of a sudden
uh they started taking heavy fire and
and i
uh i didn't know who it was but it was
grant kelper that went down
he took a round in one leg and it went
up and missed
and missed the family jewels and went
down the other leg i mean you may have
heard about that and he
and and he survived it no no femoral
artery
puncture i mean he could have been gone
and and those wounds there was a guy
shot in the chest
i'm not sure which guy there was a guy
shot in the lower abdomen
uh tom was hitting the hand and just
just
it disabled his weapon and uh
and i'm talking john it was obvious to
me i'm i'm sitting there at low level
i'm doing pedal turns literally the
aircraft and you know what happens when
you're going slow
you get retreating blade stalls called
and the aircraft starts kind of bucking
but i did that because i wanted to have
a flat profile on the aircraft
so that my right door and my left door
and earl could shoot
because we needed every weapon firing
meantime it looks like
you know and before tom even asked for
extraction i could see
that they were in extremis absolutely
more than i'd ever seen on any mission
guys in trouble you know how many guys
total did they have on the ground
they had six and so that was the the
slick carried in all
others all the six seals in one bird and
and i and i
in my haste i mentioned there i forgot
the first part of the story
on the way in i'm in front
ed ed's in the middle and my trailer
ship's behind
and we're transiting up and about 10
clicks short
of the lz the kid sitting on there
i think it was the right side of the
aircraft got hit in the shoulder radial
men got hit in the right shoulder
so and that happens when you're flying
in a hostile area
so we turned around and flew back we
went back
landed got the kids some medical help
and tom wasn't the time richard wasn't
even part of the operation
and kelper said let's go back i said
okay i'll cover you and he says and
richard says i'll go
and and i know that a couple guys uh
and i'm not sure i won't use their names
but a couple other
seals said don't but they wanted to go
so
tom hops in and off we went but the
story got kind of muffled over 50 years
because
we never got to debrief the op the guys
got wounded went to third surge
went home they were at the end of their
tour most of them had already packed up
all their stuff
except for their favorite weapon so we
never debriefed it
ever so come back to the mission here
we got loaded got tom on board and off
we went back again
now the story over the years i remember
hearing from other seals well you guys
went to the lz and then
then you went back to the same lz that's
why they got hit
that's not true it didn't happen that
way we did not even get to the ease lz
the first time
we didn't even make an approach to it
because again we just got hit
transiting the area so we went back
inserted they got in place i could see
i'm coming back to the extremist part
and uh and i called ed in and ed was
already on his way in
and thank god that ed was a former fire
team leader he knew the story he knew he
knew how to fly he had a slick with a
lot of power
and uh because i was about
a quarter of an inch from landing and
picking up myself now
that would have been the last possible
situation because
as you all know john on a hot day a sea
wolf loaded with armament
the probability you're putting six
people in taking off is
one percent if that if you could even
get airborne at all
and uh you have to understand
that these uh-1 bravos were
eight nine thousand pound airplanes and
we had them loaded with fuel a little
bit of armament
and four people in it and on a hot day
we could sometimes we couldn't even
hover
we had to take off skip along before we
got translational lift
we had to be into the wind and very
careful and be smooth
we would say i'd say to my co-pilot you
want to hold this collective
and this stick like it's a beautiful
woman you don't want an offender you
don't want to be rough you want to be
gentle
and just this think it off the ground
that's what i would say don't
pull the pitch think it up and it'll get
up okay and then we did
yep and sometimes you you hear the rpm
start going down at 6 000 red light
comes on
and get an oral and then you've got to
be kicking out
boxes of ammo in the river throwing out
your rocket pods and hoping you don't
crash
i never did did you nope you had some
close calls well
on the lst's you know the same thing
you'd barely hover
you would get it over the edge and then
it would dive for the water to get air
speed
hope you got the earth before you got to
the water and use the water to
push off the air to get a translational
lift and so
we were that heavy so i thought crap you
know and i
my guys knew we may be dumping rockets
to the bad guys and a lot of
we may need to get these people it will
wait well ed came in
he got them all i didn't see
the kid hanging on to the skid basically
i was busy we were putting fire in but
uh
thank god for tom richards on that
flight but i did see tom
dragging guys across several levees
under fire and the two guys that weren't
wounded
did a heck of a job laying down fire and
tom will tell you
to cover the extraction of those wounded
guys
grant telfer telfer's lucky to be here
in this world
and whenever i see tom richards uh
it never fails he hugs me which is not
all that nice
but he thanks me for him being on the
green side of grass
did the same thing at your house last
year sure did and
and that's uh that's a and and my
my one of my crewmen mike dobson he was
who is a heck of a guy a stellar
one of the best and we had some good
ones gunners ever and he
he says why didn't we get more awards on
that
and i said well our reward is if there
are six guys that got wounded and they
survived and they got families and most
of them i think all of them got back on
active duty
that's a big award so my wingman what
happened to my wingman
didn't answer wouldn't answer so we're
escorting the slick back to the base
with wounded people and that's on my
mind i'm calling to get the ambulance
down to get to get the guys ready and so
forth
and uh earl still calling him on the
radio
no response and all of a sudden dobson
says
sir sea wolf black blank just joined up
on us
he joined up on us well
my temperature went to i don't know a
thousand and
we landed and uh
first of all we had to get the seals
taken care of and they were
and and you know and you're kind of
coming down from a high
after that much adrenaline's going
and i talked to dear letter craft
commander
he says i don't know what happened we
just got stuck on the ground
and that's that's all i'll say but
supposedly they just went when we were
going in low
he just lost it and flew into the ground
and got stuck in the mud and couldn't
get out that's the story i get from
the co-pilot's now dead he passed away
and
from the crewman it was a sad day for
sea wolves because
and i reported that that happening to
my exo not to seal with the xo who i
knew pretty well
and uh nothing was done
pretty embarrassing if if if one of
those
i promised the aircraft commander that
was my trail ship
that if one of those seals didn't make
it he'd
he wasn't going to make it either and i
meant it
but they all made it so that's kind of a
story that hasn't been told and when
they when mike slattery wrote the
wrote the uh award recommendation and
i was talking to gordy peterson he was
also a seawolf
for a while debt one and debt two and
cordy says you mean he abandoned you and
the face of the enemy
i said damn sure did
now again the guy was suspect we
certainly didn't think he would do that
so i'm conflicted by that one i want to
kill the guy still
on the other hand uh everybody made it
out
everybody did their job my four guys tom
clavons passed on
uh mike dobson i just saw last week earl
shot
i just talked to him a few days ago he's
close to us uh
really good guy uh 100
oxygen by the way copd problems but what
a guy
yeah he's probably gonna outlive us both
john
and and you and i talked and i know
you're still connected to tom richards
who
you know as i mentioned has played a
role in changing my life for me
and uh hopefully we can talk to him and
i can get him out here to sit down in
this room and
that would be just an honor to be able
to do that
tom's changed a lot of lives one time he
was
speaking at a seawolf convention in 2004
and somebody is the camera on me now
yeah oh
and so somebody says you for two hours
admiral show me your wound he goes
his finger he got shot in the finger but
what makes it clever like this
uh tom changed a lot he's one of the
again one of the bravest nicest guys i
know
and uh it's all because of jackie i'm
sure not mine
not tom and uh just a good guy uh
and happy he's a friend of mine and
happy he's here
any other uh john any operations that
stick out in your mind
as sort of the the pinnacle of of your
tour over there
i think the one that when ben toohey got
hit or s
son and doc that one that was the big
one
flew all night long you know for like 12
hours just
putting strike after strike after strike
in so you're
so you're sitting there and the base
starts to get attacked
and is it is it the first call is that a
contingency plan that you all have hey
if we start getting attacked we're going
to get these birds out of here
well the first reaction was to get to
the bunker
just so it could you know then you know
assess the situation and then
there was that lull and i said now's the
time to go and we
we just ran out to the helos and hopped
in and
took off and how many guys were on base
defending the base or did everyone get
into either helicopters or swift boats
and get out of there
well the base was was an open area there
was no perimeter around
debt six and uh and i'm not sure there
was a perimeter around the
the barges that were on the river they
just had a whole string of barges right
there down in the river and it wasn't a
big
village or anything but uh we didn't
have any perimeter guards around
where we were and we were just a couple
hundred yards off from where the
the barges were so we just got in the
bunker and after we took off and then
we went back because we weren't sure
about the rest of the people that were
there the crew
the other pilots and so but we found out
they had gotten to the boats and
and got out how much fuel how long can
you guys fly for in the huey
when you're loaded out to bear a couple
of hours
yeah hour and a half two most flights
are pretty short
but an hour and a half was a long flight
and the 20-minute fuel light is very
accurate
i had one mission where we came back and
we literally the 20-minute fuel light
came on we went back up to
kamau which was where debt 3 was and as
we as we touched down
the engine shut itself down we ran out
of fuel as we
were touching down were you flying with
me
when we had to land
and send out for fuel because we ran out
no and we ignited
yeah well this is this is in scramble
the sea wolves right this story
yeah and tell us about that one mike
dobson was my recruitment again
and we didn't run out of fuel but i
but i landed at hattie inn because
i was at the end of the 20 minutes
and that light gets bigger and bigger
and at nighttime it's huge just like
it's sun
at daytime it's still pretty damn big
what was the mission that you were doing
we were covering seals that day and i
don't remember
what the pacific operation was the
missions all come together
i remember mike slattery asked me on the
phone time
uh how about blah blah blah and i said
you know
they all kind of blend together it's
hard to separate them out
i remember the zulu one in detail i
i dream about that one and and uh and
thank god about it every night
not every night but most nights um
but we were we were covering uh seals
and and
mike dobson could give you more detail
but uh
uh we had to make a call about
whether we we ended up with less fuel
than my wingman and we
ended up swapping stations and refueling
one time to cover
and back and forth but we i got so low i
couldn't go back
at the time the seals were already in we
were safe but so you stayed on station
to support them
absolutely even though you were low on
fuel and you you had enough fuel just to
get them
and then make it to a rice paddy
somewhere basically wells no place
called hot the end there was even
it wasn't no fuel there and it wasn't
really a landing pad there was a
rice paddie near a little town yes and
so we set a perimeter up and
we sent out for fuel and by sending that
sending out for fuel
you you grabbed ammo hamilkans and
pulled fuel from the other bird yeah and
and
uh it's pretty embarrassing you think
about how can you let yourself run out
of fuel well
sometimes you don't have and you know
the big thing is contamination you worry
about
getting fuel contaminated and but it
worked out okay we made it but that was
uh
it takes mike dobson to tell the story
he can tell it without any alcohol
he's a better storyteller than i am
mission focused
for sure so then when you guys get home
from vietnam what
what happens with your careers at this
point cause whichever
whoever was counseling you carl that
told you the rest of the navy
ain't like this he was definitely right
i know i had some new guys
that were on their first deployment when
i was in the battle of
the battle ramadi and
it's it's kind of a corrupting thing to
be in this situation where
there's very limited bureaucracy we have
total control over what's happening
you're doing the job you always dreamed
about and
i remember some of the older more
experienced guys saying
it's not going to get any better than
this this is the best deployment you're
ever going to do
so enjoy it and it sounds like you guys
got some of that advice but what was the
reality when you got back
how many of us would we went from how
three how many went to lakers
well i what i did is that uh i wanted to
go to lakehurst but i had orders to
quantum point what was lakehurst
lakehurst new jersey it was a naval air
station
and that's where uh the lamps program
started
and what was the lamps program online
light airborne multi-purpose systems and
we were they
were had helos the h2s could track
submarines
and that's submarine warfare asw
as jenny says and so what so the
detailer was actually in vietnam
and earl and carl
had already left and they were going to
lakehurst
and i had borders to quonset point and
so
the detailer wanted to go out on a
mission so i put him in the co-pilot
seat and we went out and found some
targets and let them shoot
the mini gun and everything and i told
the crew if they ran the
the mini guns dry he had to buy the crew
a case of beer
because it was so hard to re restring
and everything it's easy to just clip
the next one around and go
so i told the crew let him shoot as much
as he wants i'll buy a case of beer if
he wants to dry well he
ran the many guns dry get back and he
says you know i'd really like to go to
lakehurst
and he says i can't promise anything but
i'll see what i can do
and about i don't know four weeks later
i get my orders and they're delay cursed
beautiful and then i'm in lakehurst that
minigun solves a lot of problems on both
ends
yes but i'm in lakehurst now and i'm
walking through the hangar
and i see this commander coming the
other way and i salute him
and i'm still a jg at the time and he
sees my name tag he says far
he calls me over says i think you were
supposed to be in my squadron
and i said i don't know they gave me
orders to come here and i'm just
following orders
but that's how i ended up in lakehurst
and then that's you know and the three
of us were still real close and
became closer even then we got the
lakers a bunch of hell three guys yeah
what was almost embarrassing was
most of us had three four rows of
ribbons in them
we didn't know what most of them meant
we just we we've got
all these medals you know somebody asked
me then well what are your write-ups and
i said i don't know where were your
ribbons i don't know where's your logo
i know it's in a storage somewhere but
but we're
we're at this base and there's a bunch
of guys that either
dodged the vietnam or the unless given
the benefit of the doubt they just
didn't get a chance to go
but they're on the east coast and uh
they were resentful they were resentful
um you know
uh and they reward someone as awards
were following
us there was always quarters and you
always get another award
and i was like oh crap maybe i should
take leave
i don't want to get there and you know
sour grapes and you know i i show up
there and i got
11 1200 hours or whatever and most of
those guys got
haven't you made aircraft commanders yet
because we've been flying our bus off
and they've been on a in most well
well i think the guys from hell that
came back to the squadron like that from
hell
three we had been in combat we'd seen a
lot
and you mentioned in the book that
you've written about you know tactics
and strategy
about filling the void and just taking
charge
if you see something's not getting done
you got to step in
and take command and i think the guys
from hell 3
stepped up and they they did their jobs
better than anybody else we just stepped
up and started
getting stuff done and i can remember at
one point i was a
night maintenance officer in a squadron
and one in the bird there was always
birds down
but i was night maintenance officer and
one night we got every single
aircraft in the squadron was up and
ready
for flight the next day and i went in
the wardroom
and put on the board it says all
aircraft are ready for flight
today and uh and i think that was a nice
accomplishment to have all the birds up
that's yeah but i think taking
charge and working with the chief and
the maintenance people and
we worked late hours we they actually we
worked past
midnight one time just to get this last
bird up so you could have them all up on
that next day
that is when i got the lakers they had
10 birds
and one up forever and
our ceo was a guy and a nice guy
the first one i had when i was there mr
peanut i told you about him
he looked like the guy in the planter's
peanut yard he
and i was a line division officer i mean
i i was in charge of nothing but a bunch
of guys that
were yelling at women and doing i tried
to keep them all under control
high school guys well i really worked on
them we
trained and we got pretty damn good and
they looked
they looked almost like a troop well
there was one bird up and i had them all
trained up and i'm watching them from
the line shack
on the end which is on the end the big
blimp hanger
and the commander comes out there's ceo
and he pre-flights the aircraft and
it passed the pre-flight all right
he climbs in co-pilot climbs in
they got through the checklist okay they
plugged the power in
start one start two all right
sounds perfect everything is good
they have the guy out here playing
captain in front he had the ones and
he's holding the guy short here and so
forth we had a guy who was on the apu
there
auxiliary power you know it's like a
like a like a
four-wheeler and he turns
you know the and and the seal salutes
him he salutes him
hops back on and drives off yanks the
plug out of the side of the airplane
it's down and i ran and hid
so we were flying the h2s we were
assigned to a destroyer so that we were
landing on the back of destroyers
and we were you were like the third dead
i was on sixth dead
i went over we had lost a bird in the
med
and i they put in h2 and hc
or c5 and we flew it over and
they were just the replacement crew so
it was two pilots and a crewman
and so we got to sit in the cockpit of
the c5
flying across the atlantic we flew over
and i was sitting the cockpit and they
got a
a warning fuel light on one of the
engines and had to shut it down
if i hadn't been sitting in the thing i
would have never known they'd shut an
engine down
we had to land in madrid wait for we
waited a week for a part to finally come
then we finally got over
to naples and that's where they unloaded
the the hilo
then that flew on the the bone and
then that fluid you know flew in the med
doing asw
work well john did one story about tell
him what happened why you
what you didn't tell him was the crew
that you replaced what
they the guys you replaced the aircraft
yeah they had crashed in the met lost
the entire
lost a bird and a crew in the met we had
we were
our planes were starting to drop like
flies at that time
and he's going over there with another
approach got to be on your mind john
no i wouldn't i didn't you know you
don't think about that you know you got
a job doing it that you're thinking
about doing there and i was happy to
be in the med and we were flying you
know working the med
and the only place we really wanted to
go to was greece
and so we were pulling into greece
dropped anchor
and we were going to go on liberty all
of a sudden there was some russian subs
coming out of the adriatic we had to
pick up anchor and go chase them
so we were chasing them across and we
were actually at one point
they surfaced all their subs and we
think they were trying to sneak some
nuclear subs in
to the med so they had all the surface
ones the diesel's up on
and we were like in perfect formation 10
russian shrimps
10 u.s ships in formation going across
the mid
all of a sudden they stay all their subs
went under
aircraft are flying every which way
because we're trying to keep track of
them
and so we're flying again but you could
never get a confirmation of where they
were because there was just so much
noise in the water with all the ships
and everything
but they're flying around and they're
helicopters taking a picture of us on
our hangers we're flying around taking a
picture
of them on their hangers and stuff like
that we go all the way across the med
and the admiral from the russian ship
calls up our ambulance says thanks for
the escort across the bed and they
peeled off and went into alexandria
and that's of course when we didn't have
good relationships with uh with egypt so
but it was an interesting tour across
the bed with the russian ships
say middle east and then how long did
you guys end up staying in the navy for
i stayed on well i did a tour at
lakehurst
and then uh that's when i met my wife at
the end of my tour and i got out of the
navy
went back and worked for burrows so that
job was too late
i was still there like you were told hey
girls will always be here
it was so i went back and worked for
burls and then i i joined the reserves
so i spent uh 24 years in the reserve so
i actually
got 30 years and i retired as a captain
and i i know that you were in guam for a
chunk of time
when were you in guam when did you when
were you last in guam
oh man i was probably lasting while i'm
in the 80s
i went over there as a maintenance
officer and we there two weeks
we consider good planning to leave
chicago in february
and go to the south pacific and guam and
do our two weeks active duty good plan
so we did that
and the unit i was in there was the
uganda guam unit in oganaga was the uh
where the naval air station was there
and uh we won the bartol
trophy one year which was the best
reserve unit in all the navy
and we won that one year i think when i
was the training officer we got that
and then i became i was ceo of the
midway unit
actually got to fly out to midway on a
p3 okay landed on midway island not many
people can say they've been on midway
island
uh then it was the ceo of the uh komnerv
airland
which was uh down in norfolk
and that was a nice tour for me and then
the
the organic guam unit ran into some
tough times
and they fired the seal and they brought
me back in and we
turned that around and i found this
this uh marine poster
it was a couple a4s and it said on
top and so i took this poster
and i redid it a little bit and i says
put this poster up we're getting back on
top
and we took the the ghana guam unit back
up and then i went out there as a co
with the unit to a ghana guam and uh
and captain uh butterfield was a ceo out
there and he was
involved in that uh debacle when they
tried to get the
hostages out of iran he says we could
have used
some good healer pilots on that mission
for sure
and uh but uh so that was
like the late 80s that i was in guam i
just know i was in guam in like
1990 late 1992 or early 1993 is when i
got
there i was thinking maybe you and i
were in the navy at the same time
a few years you're looking at 275 year
old guys i'm 70s
we're 76. yeah so it's
oh go ahead but i i love guam was a
great place i like yeah that's and i had
a nice
tour with the with the reserves in my
last four years i was on the admiral
staff
as a deputy for training and readiness
up at the great lakes because they
closed
glenview at the time i thought he had
actually talked him into
keeping glenview open but i think
because we met with some of the senators
and that was when
brac was going on and everything i had
to give a speech about why we should
keep glenview open to these people
and then i had lunch with them at a
table and i thought i thought i
felt i had talked them into keeping
glenview open but i think they went
you know behind doors and says well you
can have glenview or you can have great
lakes and you
so the navy had to make a pick and they
took great lakes which now
today is the sole training center if you
go in the navy as enlisted you're going
through great lakes 100
yep but i was on the admiral staff up
there for about four years
and then i retired out of there and how
long did you stay at burroughs for
four i was at burroughs until it merged
with sperry
and i actually got my picture in the
last burl's annual report
because i had just sold the largest
computer that burrows had
to the university of chicago medical
center which was the a15
and it was a big deal then it merged
with spiri
then they went then i went to digital
and i ended up working for
saic okay yeah which is this up here in
la jolla
and uh i was in telecommunica i worked
in telecommunications and we did all the
software development
for the rbox and i had ameritech then
sbc bought ameritech and bought pack
bell
so i had offices in chicago down in san
antonio actually had an apartment
because that's where the
main executives were then out in san
ramon where
pac bell was and i can remember i was
with our president one day and i said
you know
if i put all my offices together they'd
be bigger than your office
and he looked at me and said you know i
could fix that
so i always had responsibility for all
the artbox you know kind of
those software operations for their
their backend systems and stuff
got it and so what about you carl how
long did you make it in the navy after
you got home from health
you know john admitted the part about uh
about glenview that's really important
and that was uh
i grabbed a t28 i was in that squadron
for training squadron for a while and
would take off earl and i
several times and come one time earl
shot and i know the time
uh got him tim ziemer zip as she's
referred to by some
zip and i would fly up and we'd go up
just stay in
with john and eat and sleep for free and
give him a hard time
but uh yeah i i
um i was in lakehurst there and i i
wasn't sure what i was going to do i was
still a usnr i hadn't augmented but i
was thinking about it
and uh
and steve schroeder and i were both on
track to go into believe it or not going
to the fbi
steve actually went in i didn't
i was my interviewee i never forget his
name was jay
wallace leprod he ended up running the
new york office
one of my questions in my interview i
thought has been fun i said well we got
you got
you know chad hoover and you got jay
wallace le prod and
would i be carl dean nelson or c dean
nelson
he didn't laugh he's a good guy
afterwards he said that was funny so i
it came down to
go back to school or teach or whatever
so but i
i went down with flight instructor and
went to the west coast uh
did hsl 35 um
we got picked up early for lieutenant
commander commander did my last tour
an oppo five uh i got offered a job by a
guy on a ship
on my last cruise and my wife who at
that time and
rest her sold she's passed on but she
was not a fan of the navy and didn't
like being a naval officer's wife
because you
know that's some work it's not easy and
uh
and uh so uh but we end up getting
divorced later but i always kidding say
that
my i got up because my wife didn't like
the navy but it turned out she didn't
like me i can't imagine that but so
either 10 years 11 months and nine days
navy was great to me
i can't imagine anybody was treated
better than i was treated
by the navy just a a kid from coos bay
oregon and
literally and john was saying today the
navy's got a great system of evaluating
and promoting the right people with some
exceptions he was looking at me
but other than that but i met my wife
when i was stationed at lakehurst
oh yes so i was just getting
i was just getting ready to get out of
the
active duty navy and uh
i met my wife we dated and then they
the ceo wanted me to be the onc
would take a detachment out and uh
it was the north atlantic cruise
detachment on the boat
and i says i went to him he says you
know there's people that are more
qualified to take this attachment out
than me
and he says he looked at me says you're
the most qualified
and you're going and he knew i was
dating
gene at the time so i just met gene
so we dated for a couple months and i
hit was gone for two months on this
north atlantic cruise on the bowen
and uh and carl was on with though and
sealed that
prior to me and so we both know this
knew the ceo of the ship
which was just a great guy and we were
pretty close to him and uh came back
and uh god other got out of the navy
in december got married in january and
started back at burrows in february
and somebody says you know you shouldn't
do three life-changing situations like
that in succession
she put some time between them but so we
dated
for eight months i was gone for two of
those months and we got
eight months later we got married and we
just had our
47th wedding anniversary last january
outstanding
great what did you end up doing carl and
the rest of your
once you got out of the navy uh i got
recruited to a train corporation i
i ran a office there and then uh
uh lived in huntington beach california
and and newport beach
and then got recruited to
uh boise cascade corporation office
products division
um i was general sales manager i never
sold anything in my life
i bought some stuff but i hadn't sold
anything so then then i ended up getting
recruited to
uh to the hershey organization at 11
western states up a snack and beverage
and then i did uh
a tour of crafts matter of fact a couple
times in chicago yeah
john and i had dinner there with his dad
he was a great man
john f farr senior was
no reason no wonder that he and i stayed
close and communicated
through the 50s when ike was president
he still had time
to communicate with your dad to
uh make a couple of uh phone calls for
your aunt was it
or wrist yeah and just a good guy
his dad was absolutely class act i
always sat by him
at john's wedding and other times i
always was trying to pick that man's
brain because there's a lot there
and just he was a senior executive at
canteen
corporation which was a contract feeder
for
um auto companies and so forth vending
machines yeah and vending machine and so
forth just a good guy
but anyway i did craft and then i
got recruited and met a guy on an
airplane and he had my seat
and i had a lot of frequent flyer points
and so i had 1a
first class in those days united i could
roll in after a long week and
i commuted from california worked in
chicago how about that
and uh beat myself up and uh he had my
seat and got chat
and he hired me to be my first ceo job
and so running
instead of running a uh a three a 300
million dollar
section of craft and on healthcare food
service i had a
three million dollar muffin company i
ran but
it took more work and i paid less money
and that's how smart i am so i took a
got to be part of a company going public
after that we sold that company
uh garden burger was a vegetarian garden
burger i had
a 600 acre ranch they thought i was a
cattle ranch i thought that was an ideal
candidate
but my food background to run a veggie
burger company and uh
all my employees had earrings and uh and
uh
uh flip-flops and uh what did they wear
what do they call those shoes uh uh
those leather shoes
birkenstocks i know you're talking about
and so
here i'm sitting here on a three-piece
and start shirt
almost as much starch john's got and uh
anyway it was a great deal it was a lot
of fun
and then i ended up last year i did was
start my own company
made olive oil up to 300 000 gallons a
year we were the second largest
in the u.s when i sold i got lucky
some some guys came along and made me an
offer
i didn't understand and they came back
and doubled the offer and then i
understood
so i sold i've been the luckiest guy on
the planet i got two grown daughters
three grandkids and uh they were the
grandkids helping me in the in the plant
they were always cubby was born
when i when i poured concrete they think
they owned that plant but great kids uh
great life lucky scout planet i live on
a houseboat on pine flat lake
six miles from sequoia how do you beat
that tough to beat
i was talking to to dick couch okay
and we were talking and i was and i
hadn't gotten back to him for a couple
of weeks he said what happened i said
i'm sorry
dick i dropped my phone in the lake pine
flat
he said you know what if you drop your
phone
in a lake something's going right that
sounds like a good plan
yeah and that's it that's uh it's been
great and uh
it's great to be connected with john and
his family all of them
gene didn't get much ink but gene is the
real brains of the outfit
and the reason he was nervous about
going cruising the real story behind the
back story
the man is going in is where is where
gene worked
she's about to she was a school teacher
working the man of swan inn and the
summertime
good-looking woman and she still got it
and she
she had lots of suitors and john did not
want to leave her unattended
i left my car with her when they went on
the cruise because i didn't want to
leave with my other roommate
great great group john's got a great
family and when i first went to
got orders to lakehurst i said well new
jersey
i just want to get in and out of new
jersey without meeting the jersey girl
she changed my whole perspective of
jersey girls
we have three lovely boys and eight
grandchildren
and so now i'm tired and we're just
traveling the country because one
lives in the chicago area that we're
spending some time with one lives in
boulder and his family
we just spent a week with them we're out
here in california because my oldest son
his family are out here so we're out
there out here visiting them so
great family if i can add about gene if
i had one little trivia thing she's sort
of a celebrity
other than the fact that on her id card
and military id it says commander
gene farr uh i don't know how she got
that but other than that
you ever go to jersey mike's yeah uh
subs yeah there's a picture in there of
the original
he's laughing the original jersey mike's
it was on in point pleasant wasn't it
right yes and it's the first jersey my
first
sub i ever had in 1970 and there was a
picture
of the original jersey mics and the ad
owns it now
worked there and bought it out but
there's a picture there of the beach a
point pleasant
and there's a girl is it yellow or red
the bathing suit
i think it's red yeah anyway there's a
girl in a two-piece bin suit
that's his wife
well that's outstanding that's gonna be
the most googled picture after this uh
after this podcast comes out
you're welcome gene well look we've been
going for
a little over two hours now probably a
good probably
i mean this is just a good place to wrap
it up um
barney you got anything else john i just
like to say that
i think my time in the navy it was the
best part of my life
especially that six years on this active
duty and it's been a privilege
and an honor to have served and
supported the united states
and i think more people should should
feel that way
and and to go through and do that
and the people we had that we led
hopefully we made a positive impact on
other people's lives and made it better
but
it's been a privilege and honor to to
serve our country
carl ditto i i remember
as you talked about the question about
people's attitudes and we came back and
so forth
uh my brother was uh killed in in uh
in action uh in 1968
uh i was my last week officer kennedy
school i
hadn't we're getting ready to uh
put on the bar and be for real and then
they extended us four weeks and we went
16 instead
but i met his body
in san francisco and escorted the body
from san francisco to coos bay oregon
and uh in spite of what was going on in
the country then
it was the most moving experience you
can imagine the way the airlines handled
his body with respect how they put him
on
they they put him on first took him i'm
sorry put his body on last
and took it off first when we landed how
the captain held all the people in their
seats
until my brother was off until i was
actually the aircraft
uh
and since i've been retired i've done a
lot of traveling john she's more of
eenie
and earl and tim more than me they like
but
i see a lot of good in america in spite
of
what the news programs may put out even
today the 24-hour news cycle is our
problem
i see good people out there that are
and i don't see racism at all i see good
people doing good things being kind to
each other
and particularly to an old man who
they've got no reason to be kind to
and that's me and i see it in every
state i've been
i have no bad experiences and i've
driven
probably 200 000 miles the last five
years around our country
i've even been to honduras still met a
lot of good people
i just like to i've enjoyed this and i'd
like to thank my son eric he's the one
that talked me into
doing this i'm not big on going out and
touting what i've done and things like
that so he
i'm glad he took the you know took
charge of it
and came through and you know talked to
helen and got this arranged and i've
enjoyed
the two hours that we've spent here with
you and i've looked at some of your
broadcasts and
enjoyed them as well so i want to thank
you for
having us and i want to thank eric for
helping arrange it for me
absolutely thanks to eric and and thanks
to both of you
um obviously thanks for coming on and
sharing your story
and sharing the story of of what you all
did
more important thanks for what thanks
for what you guys did
for america and um
and for going out and holding the line
and on top of all that um
a profound thank you and a solemn salute
to the 44 members of the sea
wolves pilots and gunners
that were killed in action in vietnam
and who gave their lives
for us and to take care of my
forefathers
in the seal teams we will not forget
their sacrifice
thanks for coming on thank you john
thank you
and with that carl nelson and
john farr sea wolves have left the
building
always good to hear those stories man
i'm glad we're able to capture them this
is a unit that was
founded and commissioned in vietnam
and then decommissioned in vietnam this
the whole life of
the sea wolves was in vietnam that's it
i'm pretty sure most highly decorated
naval air squadron
in history which is also kind of crazy
so good to be able to pass on these
uh capture these stories
appreciate them coming on here and
well these guys were always ready to go
echo charles yeah i'm thinking that we
should probably do
our best so we are also always ready
to go what do you think yes i agree
it's gonna stay capable that's kind of
the deal that's the gig
so what do we do we're working out we're
reading obviously
we're doing jiu jitsu thankfully
come on you gotta be thankful for that i
always think there was a time where we
were doing a lot less jiu-jitsu
we don't like that at all capability hit
some challenges all good though we're
back we're doing jiu jitsu
we're reading we're working out we're
maintaining relationships as well
forget about that kind of stuff so
through this path that we're all on
you run into some pain yep unfortunately
it's the truth it's reality
pain is part of it we'll see
pain and suffering okay i'm overstating
that
because it isn't a level of suffering
because you're gonna suffer regardless
if you're not on the path you're gonna
suffer those consequences of not being
on the path
if you're on the path you're gonna
suffer what the path
gives you something so you're gonna need
some help
we got help choco fuel supplementation
for your body and for your brain so
first thing we have is jocko
discipline go in a can
in a powder and in the capsule so
speaking of the cans
these are your energy drinks of today
the real energy drinks modern updated
updated upgraded upgraded beneficial
benevolent
but yeah benevolent sure that's what
they are they're good they are they're
good for you energy drink that you get
all the front end benefits of
energy drink and then you get back in
benefits rather than back in
detriments as it were back in the day i
like where you're going with this not
like that so yes this bingo
uh you can get them at wawa you can get
them at vitamin shop
you can get them on jockofill.com also
with jaco has this stuff for your
immunity stuff for your joints stuff for
your uh additional protein that you
might need
keep in mind this additional protein
mulch it's called mulch
[Music]
is the best tasting
protein that there is in fact
even if you were to start ranking just
straight up desserts
like if you just started ranking
desserts straight up
it's on it's in the game i mean it's
beating there's a lot of desserts
in my opinion it's straight up beating
right oh yeah
and legit desserts too yeah that it's
beating um
let's see there's a whole a whole genre
of cakes in fact
most cakes are getting beat by mulk in
my opinion i usually think cakes are dry
okay so you're correct actually and
using a little case study so my
mother-in-law is in town
cool and she likes these things like i
they're almost like shortbread cakes
okay and they come in this lavish like
container
and like half of them are like coated
with i don't know what to call icing or
whatever you call that
and the one that at some point it was
soft and now it hardened and now it's a
shell but it's like
anyway i forget i forget what they're
called but they're whatever so i'm like
okay cool
yeah and so my did you get that hitter
yeah you know
i got into them okay just to see what up
you know
they look good yeah so i was like cool
and i eat one i was like oh yeah yeah
it's like of course good keep in mind i
wasn't evaluating
it like this at the time but i'm like
cool good
thinking back on those things whatever
they were called milk is better milk is
straight up better milk is better
oh yeah and i'm talking about this front
end tastes straight
oh yeah just the sheer pleasure of
drinking milk
is better than those cakes and the thing
is the cakes weren't like
oh these are like surprisingly junk
they're stale
they came through for what they were
doing yeah this one's also better if you
start graphing
all desserts yeah like moke is
is in the upper percentage correct and
there's
and it's absolutely good for you yep
yep so there you go that's the good news
right now i think uh
the you know belittle for the
for the design is going to get a nobel
eat prize
right hey man we got to put that stuff
together it's hard to make that stuff
taste so good
it's not easy yeah i would think we go
through iteration after iteration after
iteration to make it taste that good
it's not like oh cool here's you know
the ingredients put them in there now it
tastes good no it's
hard what's weird is like i didn't think
about that and one
belittle was kind of explaining i was
like oh that makes sense and then i
realized oh [ __ ] that applies to a lot
of stuff then
because okay so we're doing like flavor
testing for the energy this is for is
this for your drink
you know mango mayhem we're we're doing
some
tasting and stuff so he's like hey what
do you think about this is before when
we're doing grape or whatever
he's like what do you think about this i
was like yeah i want it to be like more
more like i need more of this particular
flavor or whatever
he's like okay cool but keep in mind
that in turn does this to it and it's
like oh man this is like a balance it's
a balancing act
so you gotta balance it perfect yeah and
sometimes straight up and this is what
happened with that particular flavor
he's like sometimes
it simply won't work given what you're
trying to do
just simply won't work otherwise you've
got to either add sugar
which that's the main thing you just got
to add sugar right which we're not doing
we're not doing it exactly right so the
same thing for milk
same thing for like those malt bars like
everything i was like oh man you guys
got some
you have a task that's a hard job oh
yeah
but i think the nobel eats prize is
gonna go to belittle
yeah and the jocko fuel uh what
are they the food team they're making
the they're making it
yeah mixing it up fedexing it to me
so if you want any of that stuff go to
jockofield.com by the way look
we know that shipping can be expensive
and we know that there's other
let's say global organizations in the
world that offer free shipping
if you're a member of their little club
[Music]
okay
cool and that's good i'm not taking away
from that
that's a good business model we know
that we have to offer something so that
we can also give you
the equivalent value so check it out if
you
subscribe to any of these things you
don't have to pay for shipping shipping
is free
you know what i thought of actually just
now about the
some global organizations and their free
shipping situation yeah
you pay a membership fee for that oh so
we're not it's not even free
it's yeah it's not free at all
if you buy nothing yeah they scammed you
you still pay
you're still paying guess what you're
still paying so
that's kind of the better uh what do you
call it like the superior
element in this hey if you don't it's
not weird they trick you
pay us money and it's free it's one of
those switcheroos you know
it's like no no you got free shipping
now just for the
ability to have free shipping just pay
us a membership
fee that's really strange all right with
the catch
uh yep there you go vitamin shop you can
also get it at you can also get it at
wawa for the drinks
and people are asking a lot about a lot
of other retailers
across the country we're working on all
of them we got
the team is out there all the time there
we are we're getting our
our our phone rings all day long which
is awesome because people want the
the distributors the stores want to have
it in there
and we are getting it in there we're
being strategic
we don't want to out do our supply chain
right now as we build out
our logistic capabilities this is a
military operation
right this doesn't mean we're going to
be overly cautious i mean we're going to
push the envelope and we've been pushing
the envelope you know there's been
sometimes
running a little bit thin on the
logistics train but we're still pushing
forward
but we don't want to totally overwhelm
our logistic train so we are we're
getting there
it's taking a little longer than we
wanted to understood but
we want a solid base to get there so
if you we're working on it
and we will be worldwide we'll be
nationwide pretty quick
we're working on it so everyone can have
the benefits yeah yeah it's true i feel
kind of bad
with all the benefits just in my
cupboard
also origin usa this is where you can
get your
american-made stuff denim
for jeans yep we got boots got wallets
and belts and whatnot
jiu-jitsu stuff yep by the way since
we're talking about
nam today this if you don't know this
the seals
in nam much of the time wore jeans
why do they wear jeans because they were
more comfortable
more durable and better so you can see
all kinds of pictures of the seals and
nom
you can see them in the mekong delta
wearing jeans and guess what we have a
pair of jeans
based on that history and they are
called delta
68. and i'm talking about 1968.
is there anything cooler than delta 68
for jeans it's going to be very hard to
find
they're they're they're the most
comfortable genes you will ever put on
your body
and by the way they're also as
comfortable as whatever else you could
put on your legs as a human
there's nothing more comfortable i
probably would agree with that if i had
some
but oh that's a bummer that's completely
my fault by the way
that's my fault i should have had the
whole world revolve around you more
probably right well actually technically
all i wear is shark fin
shorts which are from origin by the way
by the way
i don't know if they i think they might
be sold out of those so that's a whole
nother story nonetheless they do have
ghees and rash guards for jiu jitsu as
well yeah all kinds of jujitsu stuff
compression stuff like all kind of all
made in america too by the way i know i
said that one time but the way i said it
is indicating that it's not as big of a
deal as it really is
not to get crazy here but if you need a
ghee get an orange and gee for sure
get a rift key because it's next level
it's another thing
it's another it's another it's a
complete elevation from whatever
kind of gee you've ever worn in your
life the rift gee is a totally new ball
game
it's freaking awesome so if you if you
need a ghee get yourself a rift key oh
yeah so yeah again originusa.com
check out all their stuff on there
because a lot of stuff for me to go down
the list right now and say all this
stuff is going to take a long time
so go on there check i don't have that
kind of patience right now no and
believe me i'm patient to be sitting
here with you
freaking time and time again as you put
me through this but it's all good bro i
understand fully
nonetheless that that's that's what it
is also jacquard has a store is called
jaco store
the og since day one day five
not day one day five uh so you go to
jackostore.com this is where you can get
this one
equals freedom shirts and hoodies and
hats some rash guards on there
get after it shirts hats tank tops
good if you know what that means you say
good if you know what that means you
want to represent that's where you can
get your shirts
and hats and hoodies we got shorts on
there as well
so yeah a lot of good stuff on there um
we also have a free shipping
subscription situation and it's not the
kind you got to pay for a membership
just to have it
you get a shirt every month
a little bit different designs free
shipping on that one as well but yeah
it's called the short locker so that's
on jacko's store as well so yeah if you
want to check out
check out that if you like that and by
the way all the stuff that we're talking
about
if you want to support want to give that
support to the podcast this is how you
do it
otherwise it's like oh we will run you
know people are out there running
advertisements for um
stuff yeah stuff that you actually don't
want registry cleaner for your
uh computer look nothing against
registry cleaners for your computer hard
drives but you don't want to hear about
that when we're talking about freaking
uh huey gunships and we don't want to
tell you about that
while we're talking about huey gun chips
so all the stuff
jacofuel.com jackostore.com
originusa.com if you want to sell porch
we appreciate it you know what's
interesting and this i was talking to
jail
our boy jill joe moss and yeah and he
reminded me of this
and i know i know this i know this like
it's
the back of my hand is that the
expression anyway i know this but every
once in a while when i'm reminded of it
i'm
reminded of the for like a better term
interestingness of it
where all this stuff origin jeans
jocko store stuff jackal fuel stuff this
is all stuff that
you that we actually use now and have
before
even like these exist
this is like just the better version now
like shirt you're wearing right now oh
that's from dracula store right there
the hoodie that i wear jackal store the
shorts that i wear literally like these
shorts
are so worn out because they wear them
every single day
that like it has the outline from my
cell phone like on the pocket or
whatever
or drinks that we're drinking oh yeah
origin shorts though by the way yeah
like it's all i have
i have jacostore.com shorts on right now
exactly right with the digital pattern
oh yeah so
it's not like camo oh yeah that's one of
the options for sure
so it's not like oh yeah support the
podcast by um
buying some keychains that we sort of
just made up or whatever
which would be kind of cool i guess
these teams are cool because i use
keychains
but they're not arbitrary things you're
running around with your black belt
keychain now
that was a gift yeah charles if you see
him
maybe you forgot he's a black belt don't
worry you won't forget for long because
he's got it on his keychain
he's like hey do you want me
here let me put these keys on the table
where they're visible okay
okay there you go first off that was a
gift from mike from jiu jitsu magazine
okay i want him to do disrespect him
by putting it somewhere all i'm saying
is
we know we will all know you're a black
belt when your keys go on the table
which is where they always go in front
of everyone
anyway what i was trying to tell our
people
is that this is stuff that we use
anyway even before it existed so it's
not some arbitrary thing we're saying
hey support the podcast by the way we'll
give you this
this moderately valued thing yeah you
know it's like these are things that are
like when you're in the game on the path
they're legitimately there as well so
check hey subscribe to the podcast also
check out a jocko unraveling podcast
that's me and daryl cooper dc talking
about
all kinds of stuff grounded podcasts we
got the warrior kid podcast we got jocko
underground.com that's our own
platform right we can't just be we can't
just be uh
parasites on these big platforms cause
guess what the
the big platform might decide they're
gonna scrape you off
and now what are you gonna do starve to
death die
we're not gonna let that happen we gotta
have a contingency plan if the big
platforms decide to
scrape off us because we're over there
no we have our own platform
it's called
jockonunderground.comground.com
you are helping us build it just in case
these people get
squirrely and they start injecting
their behaviors into what we're doing
that's one see that's the cool thing
about a podcast the cool thing about a
podcast is you can do it well
if you are doing the podcast
in an in an old-school way which is hey
we're just going to do what we want then
you can do whatever you want we can
literally do whatever we want on this
podcast
but what if platforms said well actually
we don't want you to do that or we want
you to do this or we're going to put an
advertisement in there whatever that
whatever they're going to do they can do
right
yeah so we don't want to allow someone
else to control
what we are doing so therefore
if you want to help us out you can go to
jockowunderground.com and we're making
we make another little podcast for that
we're talking about
interesting topics adjacent topics
it costs money it costs eight dollars
and eighteen cents a month to keep it
rolling but uh if look if you can't
afford that we get it
we're not trying to exclude you from the
team
movement you can email
assistants at jackonground.com and we'll
take care of that appreciate the stop
porch
we also have a youtube channel by the
way yep speaking of platforms
we have a youtube channel this is where
i put in a lot of work
creatively as the assistant director to
many of these videos the good ones
and if you want to check out my work you
want to see what
what the the really the pinnacle of
assistant directing
yeah you can check some of these videos
out on
jocko podcast youtube channel yeah
yeah the epitome is always or the
pinnacle of assistant directing
so my daughter she's eight by the way so
keep keep that in mind okay
before you fly off the handle so she you
know she's like oh yeah you and jack are
youtubers and i'm like oh
okay ah you know maybe maybe not depends
on what you mean or whatever
so she's like hey what is like well what
does jocko do
then you know i look more he writes
books or whatever he's like yeah but he
already wrote those books
like what does he do yeah what's he
doing now yeah like what does he do
and you know eight years old you hear
what do you do you that's what you think
right you think what do you do
what do you do when you wake up like
what does he do she knows what i do
i play on the computer all day she knows
that you know kind of thing she
understands
so anyway so i was like oh you know
whatever he does
his thing she goes jocko hardly does
anything
like you she goes she said straight up
you do most like you do pretty much
everything
and then so i kind of laughed i was like
yeah you're right jacob just talks she's
like she's like yeah he just talks like
you're the one who has to film
you're the one who has to come on with
the song you're the one because she sees
everything i do you know
so that's her next time she says
something like that i'll be like well
you know
um he does he is the assistant director
on some of these videos
so you know so now we know i am i am
i am an employed individual yep my my
work is is the pinnacle of
effort yes you're doing your part
jack so yes youtube channel we do have
one
uh also we have psychological warfare
it's an album
we made jocko made technically
of him helping me through moments of
weakness that i might have from time to
time
then we extended it to other weaknesses
that others might have from time to time
so what you do pop that in when you're
feeling them all you're going to skip
that workout you put it in
he's going to tell you why why you
should not do that it's a good one
if you want something to hang on your
wall get something cool to hang on your
wall
from dakota meyer flipsidecanvas.com is
going to send you
a bunch of cool designs check them out
and you're supporting dakota meyer and
if you're doing that like your whole day
is good
in my opinion uh got some books
final spin this is not a book about
leadership
there may or may not be some leadership
lessons in there it's more a book about
life
and death and the and the journey
that human beings go through and the
pitfalls that they fall into and how
they rise out of those
or don't you can check that out
it's coming out if you want to get the
first edition
get best order now because you know the
publisher's like well you know
we don't want to invest too much and
that's becoming yeah it's like okay cool
so they're not going to print enough
you're not going to get one unless
you're in the game
get in the game also leadership strategy
and tactics field manual the code the
evaluation of protocol
displays freedom field manual there's a
new version out that has my
head on it but it's bigger than my
original head sure
my head is grown
[Laughter]
way the warrior kid one two three and
four mikey and the dragons
about face by hackworth which i was
honored to write the forward
for extreme ownership and the dichotomy
of leadership
the first two books i wrote about
leadership with my brother
leif babin we have echelon front which
is a leadership consultancy
and what we do is solve problems through
leadership we have an online training
platform
ef online.com on there all the time
courses on there get your team aligned
you don't i don't need to come out to
your location good deal dave burke
doesn't need to come out to your
location
leif babin doesn't need to come out to
you look at where we're in your location
virtually check that out
we have some some live events that we do
one of them is called the muster and is
two day leadership
seminar the next one is in phoenix
august
17th and 18th and then las vegas october
28th and 29th
go to extremeownership.com if you want
to get in the game there
we have something i don't even know if
this will be out yet we have the ftx
which is a field training exercise you
learn tactics
you apply the tactics with laser weapons
you apply the leadership tactics that we
talk about all the time
and they will be ingrained into your
brain
when you are done with the field
training exercise massive lessons
learned and if you want to help service
members
active and retired their families gold
star families
check out mark lee's mom she has a
charity organization
she gets one of the things that she's
doing is getting
medical treatment for service members
that the government doesn't cover and
she'll cover the whole bill
so if you want to help service members
get those medical treatments
you can donate or get involved at
america's mighty mightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my grueling
ruminations
or you need more of echo's hypnotic
hypotheses
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on the gram
and on facebook echoes attica charles i
am at jacqueline and thanks once again
to
john farr and carl nelson thanks to
john's son
maureen for getting us linked up thanks
for sharing your stories gentlemen and
thank you
for your incredible service to our great
nation and thanks to all the sea
wolves themselves that flew in vietnam
and risked their lives and sometimes
gave their lives
for their brothers in arms on the ground
and to all our military personnel and
veterans around the world
thank you for what you do and what you
have done
to protect freedom and our way of life
and the same goes
to our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service
and all first responders thank you for
protecting us
when we need you and to everyone else
out there
you never know when the call will come
and you never know
how much time you will have
in fact you don't know how much time you
have so don't wait
don't hesitate don't procrastinate
instead
like the mighty sea wolves
of helicopter attack squadron 3
go out there and get after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out